Unverkennbar, die Klänge des Chaosradios auf Fritz. Jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat ist es soweit hier. Da wird der Blue Moon umfunktioniert und drei Stunden lang wird getalkt. Und zwar mit dem Chaos Computer Club im Studio. Heute zugegen Frank Rosengard vom Chaos Computer Club und meine Person von Fritz Max von Malodki. Thema heute Abend historisch.
Seit 80 Jahren gibt es Rundfunk in Deutschland. Das nehmen wir heute zum Anlass, mal die letzten 80 Jahre Revue passieren zu lassen und in die Zukunft auf die nächsten 80 Jahre zu schauen. Was bedeutet Radio für euch und warum wünschen sich viele Leute mal selber Radio zu machen? Und wie sieht eigentlich euer Radioformat der Zukunft aus? Wir sprechen heute mit einem ehemaligen Radioperaten, und wir erfahren etwas über den Unterschied zwischen offenen Kanälen und freien Radios und wie man eigentlich selbst mal für eine Woche legal Radio machen kann.
Das alles heute Abend auf Fritz und möchten euch das natürlich einfach nicht so erzählen, sondern wir möchten, dass ihr mit uns drüber sprecht. Und wir haben uns gedacht, 80 Jahre Radio, das ist wieder so ein Brocken. Also wir haben da gesessen, haben gedacht, oh man, worüber sollen wir jetzt mit den Leuten reden? 80 Jahre, das ist so ein Monument, das ist so fett. Du kannst doch nicht irgendwie über alles Mögliche reden, dann sofort in irgendwelche speziellen Details, die heiß werden, die wieder nur Radiomacher an sich eigentlich beantworten könnten. Und deswegen haben wir uns gedacht, fragen wir euch am Anfang doch mal, was ist für euch, die ihr schon seit Jahren wahrscheinlich Radio hört, das Tolle am Radio? Was war vielleicht eine Geschichte, wo ihr gesagt habt, hey, das habe ich gerne gehört und das hat mich beeindruckt, das war irgendwie eine Sportreportage oder das war ein Song oder das war ein DJ, der besonders geil aufgelegt hat oder eine Moderation, die mich inspiriert hat, zum Lachen gebracht hat oder was auch immer. 0331 70 97 110 ist die Nummer der Hotline von Fritz. Wir werden gerne mit euch talken und geben euch jetzt aber auch erstmal ein bisschen Musik. Auch eine Sache, für die das Radio steht, von DJ Cole, der im Namen des Chaos Computer Clubs heute Abend auflegt.
Genau, der ist aus Wien und spielt sonst auch im Club Bougalou in Niederbayern.
Ich heiße Fritz, das Chaosradio.
Kurz nach zehn, wir haben gerade erst losgelegt, drei Stunden Talk zusammen mit dem Chaos Computer Club im Studio, Frank und Max und im Hintergrund musikalisch aktiv DJ Cole aus Wien, der uns auch die ganzen drei Stunden noch beglücken wird. Thema heute, 80 Jahre Radio. Eine ganz schön lange Zeit, das Radio hat sich natürlich auch dick weiter entwickelt. Am Anfang war das nur so ein relativ schwer verständliches, relativ dumpfes Gebrummel. Das hat sich mittlerweile geändert. Mittlerweile versteht man Stimmen, wie sie sind. Und es hat sich auch viel geändert in der Berichterstattung. Früher ging es da viel um Sportereignisse und sowas, was es heute auch noch ist. Aber da wir natürlich andere Medien haben, die Wichtigkeit erreicht haben, ist das nicht mehr so im Vordergrund. Was ist bei Radio eigentlich noch im Vordergrund? Darüber werden wir heute Abend auch sprechen. Einstiegsfrage für euch ist aber, was ist das, was ihr an Radio toll findet? Wo habt ihr gesagt, wow, das macht Radio für mich aus, darum höre ich gerne Radio. Oder ist Radio für euch vielleicht auch nur noch so ein Nebenbei-Medium und ihr sagt, ja, nu, ich hatte früher drei Geschwister, wenn da im Hintergrund nichts läuft, fühle ich mich einsam. Das kann ja auch sein.
Oder ist Radio vielleicht schon ganz tot. Richtig. Sagt ihr schon, ah, das sind nur noch die letzten Zuckungen hier, die es irgendwie gibt von Fritz und...
Sind wir eigentlich schon arbeitslos. 0331 77 97 110, die Nummer von Blue Moon. Wir würden uns freuen, wenn ihr euch beteiligt. Das macht der Enno aus Bochum nämlich auch. Hallo Enno. Radio, das Tollste für dich an Radio oder warum ist Radio schön und gut?
Na, also ich finde das Schöne ist einfach, dass man praktisch überall Radio hören kann. So beim Autofahren, wenn man rumläuft, so es lenkt eigentlich so sehr ab. Also man kann irgendwas anderes dabei tun, so bei Fernsehen muss man hingucken, aber Radio... Also ich hab's im Prinzip 24 Stunden am Tag laufen. So, wenn ich mich gerade Fernsehen aufs Radio mit.
Kannst du dich hier noch konzentrieren auf das, was du tust, wenn gerade mal was Spannendes im Radio läuft oder unterbrichst du das denn oder wie läuft das?
Ja, wenn es richtig spannend wird, dann wird es schwierig. Aber dann hab ich ja was Spannendes im Radio, das ist dann ja genauso gut. Aber im Normalfall ist ja meist nur so Musik, ein bisschen Talk zwischendurch und das kann man denke ich ganz gut so im Hintergrund laufen lassen.
Was hörst du da so in Bochum?
In Bochum hör ich eigentlich fast gar kein lokales Radio. Ich hör meist entweder den Fritz Stream oder so ein Dortmunder Studentenradio.
Und was ist an denen besonders? Also gut, jetzt Fritz müssen wir jetzt nicht Lob hudeln bis zum Dort hinaus. Wir hören ja auch alle hier Fritz, sonst wird er ja jetzt nicht hier. Aber zum Beispiel uns interessiert ja auch der Blick in andere Medien, warum andere interessant sind. Ein Studentenradio zum Beispiel. Die werden wahrscheinlich nicht so ultra professionell sein. Warum sind die für dich attraktiv?
Zum einen, weil sie, sagen wir, eine sehr verwandte Denkensart haben. Also zum Beispiel ist die Bielefeldverschwörung Programm bei denen oder ähnliche Dinge.
Was ist die Bielefeldverschwörung?
Das ist eine lange Geschichte.
Ich glaube, da könnte man ganze Sendungen zu machen.
Also Bielefeld gibt es nicht, ist so eine kurze Sache.
Und wieso es Bielefeld nicht gibt, das ist eine lange Geschichte. Auf jeden Fall die Leute in diesem Radio wussten, Bielefeld gibt es nicht.
Und da wurde ich doch hellhörig. Das war so, wo ich dann auf einmal doch ins Radio gehört habe. Und beim Lesen der Homepage dieser Leute fielen einem noch mehr so Sachen auf, dass ich dachte, komisch, die scheinen ja ähnliche Bücher zu lesen wie ich. Und gerade diese Unprofessionalität macht es eigentlich interessant. Also wenn sich einer verspricht, dann sagt er nicht, oh mein Gott, ich habe mich versprochen. Sondern das ist dann halt so. Oder wenn man gerade keine Lust hat, ins Mikrofon zu reden, dann wird das so kundgetan, dass gerade einfach keiner Lust hat, eine Moderation zu machen. Das finde ich eigentlich so ganz lustig, weil es so ein bisschen selbstgemacht wirkt, aber irgendwie immer interessant ist und nicht so das Normale, was man vom Radio kennt.
Wenn du sagst, du hörst zum Beispiel auch Fritz über Stream, über Internet, ist das für dich so das Medium der Zukunft eigentlich? Oder wie siehst du da die?
Ich denke nicht zwingend der Zukunft.
Ich denke, das geht so miteinander her.
Zum Beispiel, wenn ich unterwegs bin, wäre es ziemlich blöd, Fritz rüber zu streamen, weil dafür einfach irgendwie die Geräte noch nicht wirklich funktional sind.
Also dass ich Fritz bundesweit oder weltweit hören kann. Also im Auto höre ich dann irgendwelches Radio, was halt irgendwie gerade nett ist. Also sofern ich da Radio höre, aber so zu Hause.
Also ich denke, Radio wird irgendwie auch nicht aussterben oder so.
Das ist einfach eine Sache.
Ja, es ist äußerst angenehm, so es funktioniert eigentlich immer.
Irgendwie man braucht nicht große, teure Geräte für.
Es gibt immer was, was man hören kann. Also so eine einfache Sache, irgendwie an Information und Musik und so zu kommen. Also wesentlich einfacher als jetzt Internet, Fernsehen oder sonst was, denke ich.
Ich frage mich manchmal, weil wir ja auch heute über die Zukunftszukunft sprechen möchten. Radio ist, hast du gesagt, das ist für dich nebenbei Medium. Das ist auch immer sehr wichtig. Es wird gesagt, man kann es wirklich parallel machen. Nur habe ich festgestellt, dass auch neue Generationen von jungen Leuten, dass die viel stärker Sachen parallel machen können, als wir das immer noch können. Und ich halte mich ja noch eigentlich immer einigermaßen für frisch im Kopf. Aber so diese Multitasking-Geschichte wird immer stärker verfügbar, auch für jüngere Menschen. Und vielleicht muss man demnächst auch gar nicht mehr so viele Sachen nebenbei machen. Zum Beispiel Autofahren und Radio hören. Das ist ja so ein Ding, das zusammengehört. Weil Autofahren ist so eine Tätigkeit, wo man den Ohr sozusagen frei hat, es sei denn für die Hupe. Und vielleicht muss man irgendwann seine Autos nicht mehr selber steuern. Also kann man dabei zum Beispiel Fernsehen. Also sowas könnte Radio auch zum Aussterben bringen.
Ich denke eher nicht.
Also ich denke schon, als Fernseher kam, hieß es, Radio sterben aus. Oder als Videorekorder kam, hieß es, es geht keiner mehr ins Kino oder so.
Ich denke, das ist wieder so eine Sache, wo irgendwie die Leute Angst haben. Aber man hat sich so dran gewöhnt. Also ich denke, wenn man guckt, wie viele Radios es in Deutschland gibt. Also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass jeder Einwohner mindestens eins hat. Und das zeigt ja irgendwie, dass es auch genutzt wird. Zumindest morgens beim Frühstück haben die meisten Leute, glaube ich, keine Lust, wegen Fernsehen zu gucken.
Sondern so im Halbschlaf, dann googelt das irgendwie vor sich hin.
Man kriegt noch Nachrichten mit vielleicht. Und ich denke, da irgendwie gibt es keinen guten Ersatz für, dass man eh nicht so aufnahmefähig, dass man froh, wenn es so einfach automatisch rumläuft und gut ist.
Aber das heißt, dass das Radio für dich im Prinzip eine Dudelkiste ist?
Nee, das nicht. Also ich finde es ganz angenehm, das immer im Hintergrund laufen zu haben. Aber es gibt ja richtig spannende Sachen. Also Chaosradio höre ich selbstverständlich immer gerne. Und ich denke, es gibt auch irgendwie sehr interessante und spannende Sendungen auch, die ich dann aber meist weniger gezielt höre, weil ich irgendwie immer verpeil, das zu hören, was ich eigentlich hören wollte. Also ich habe es im Prinzip so laufen, um mir die interessanten Informationen rauszuziehen. Also wie zum Beispiel jede Stunde die Nachrichten, so irgendwie man weiß immer, was los ist, aber man weiß eigentlich gar nicht, woher es kommt.
Das finde ich einen ganz praktischen Effekt. Also man kriegt was mit von der Welt, man kann irgendwie Musik hören, man hört vielleicht andere Meinungen zu irgendwelchen Themen in Talkshows oder so.
Und muss sich aber nicht so gezielt darauf konzentrieren, sondern es wird einem so von dem Radio einfach mitgebracht.
Und gibt es irgendwas, was du dir wünschen würdest jetzt so abschließend, wo du sagen würdest, das würde ich mir von meinem Radio wünschen, das würde mir noch fehlen, beim perfekten Radio, da würde ich gerne mehr davon haben?
Eigentlich nicht.
Also ich denke, das kommt immer ganz drauf an, was ich gerade hören will.
Also ich würde meinen, so wie es jetzt ist, ist es eigentlich schon ziemlich gut.
Also die Sendung könnten mehr meine Interessenssperrpunkte treffen. Das kann man sich ja immer nur wünschen.
Aber ansonsten denke ich, das Radio, so wie es jetzt ist, ist eigentlich eine gute Sache.
Gut, dann nehmen wir das mal so mit. Vielen Dank für deinen Anruf, Enno. 0331 77 97 1 1 0. Eure Meinung ist gefragt. 80 Jahre Radio stehen an und deswegen die Frage an euch. Was ist das Tollste am Radio? Was gefällt euch am besten an diesem Medium oder was gefällt euch nicht? Und wo hat es euch gekickt oder nicht? Oder ist es vielleicht sogar schon tot? Das möchten wir natürlich heute Abend noch ergründen. Am Telefon ist der Benny aus Berlin-Friedrichshain.
Hallo Benny.
Hallo. Dein schönstes Erlebnis?
Ja, das kann ich jetzt nicht so sagen, weil Radio ist für mich einfach ein gleichberechtigtes Medium, wie Fernseher oder auch Zeitungen oder sonst was. Also ich kann nicht sagen, dass ich das lieber mag, aber ich höre halt das, was ich sagen kann. Ich höre Fritz am liebsten, weil es da Sachen gibt, die es bei anderen Sendern zum Beispiel im Radio nicht gibt. Zum Beispiel wie diesen Blumen. Das finde ich eine sehr spezielle Sache, was auch wirklich Spaß macht, wo man da auch stundenlang zuhören kann. Da schalte ich einfach zum Beispiel bei anderen Sachen weg. Das stelle ich dann auch vor den Fernseher oder vor die Zeitung, dass ich dann halt, wenn eine interessante Sendung läuft, auch da mal wirklich drei Stunden zuhören kann.
Also bist du, wenn du sagst, es ist ein gleichberechtigtes Medium, auch nicht wirklich Passivhörer, sondern wirklich Aktivhörer. Ich mache jetzt an, ich höre jetzt zu, ich gucke quasi meinem Radio zu, wie es mir was zu Gehör bringt.
So würde ich das auch nicht sagen. Also ich weiß ja mittlerweile schon, ich bin ja schon auch eine Weile Fritz-Fan. Und ja, wann irgendwie was läuft, also um welche Uhrzeit. Also ich weiß halt, dass am Mittwoch der Soundgarden vorher kommt und dann danach ein Blue Moon auf jeden Fall. Um welches Thema es geht, weiß man ja vorher nie.
Eine Sekunde, bevor das einreißt. Der Paul hat vorhin im Soundgarden behauptet, über dessen Soundgarden reden wir jetzt gerade, dass ich ihn verprügeln würde, wenn er etwas falsch macht. Das stimmt nicht. Bevor ich jetzt ganz viele Mails bekomme, ich würde Paul van Dyck etwas antun. Das stimmt nicht. Okay, du kannst weitermachen. Verdammt, jetzt habe ich dich unterbrochen, ich Depp. Also du warst dabei, dass deine Sendungsstruktur, du hast mittlerweile relativ viel Fritz gehört und du weißt, wo was kommt und weißt, wo du deine Lieblingssendung hast. Da war ich stehen geblieben.
Genau. Und wie gesagt, dann stelle ich das auch über alles andere, was es an Medien gibt, sogar über meinen PC, den ich über alles liebe.
Könntest du dir vorstellen, auch gezielt Radiesendungen anzuhören? Also angenommen, es gäbe die Möglichkeit, praktisch wie auf einem Web-Server oder so, dass du irgendwas anklickst, dass du dann sozusagen On-Demand zum Beispiel Radiesendungen abrufst?
Ja, das wäre vielleicht was für mich, ja, auf jeden Fall.
Das heißt also, du brauchst nicht dieses Gefühl, dass da immer was läuft, sondern du hättest auch Lust, dir tatsächlich mal was gezielt auszuwählen davon?
Auf jeden Fall, natürlich. Weil ich meine, ich höre auch natürlich oftmals so rein, aber wie gesagt, ich bin halt eher interessiert an den Blue Moons, an irgendwelche Musiksendungen wie Soundgarn, als die anderen Sachen, so Nachrichten und so. Das interessiert mich eigentlich nicht wirklich. Das kann ich mir auch in der Zeitung durchlesen. Also da bin ich jetzt nicht auf das Medium Radio speziell bezogen.
Und gibt es irgendwas, was du dir noch wünschen würdest beim Radio? Das haben wir gerade auch schon mal gestellt, die Frage, wo du sagen würdest, davon würde ich mir mehr wünschen oder ich würde mir wünschen, dass es in diese Richtung mehr geht?
Eigentlich nicht, also müsste ich jetzt, also spontan fällt mir nichts ein, dann müsste ich jetzt länger drüber nachdenken. Also kann ich nicht meckern.
Macht es mal. Ansonsten, wenn dir was einfällt und für alle anderen auch, die keine Lust haben anzurufen, unsere E-Mail-Adresse ist 86 at chaosradio.ccc.de, also 86 at chaosradio.ccc.de. Für Sachen für diese Sendung jetzt.
Können wir die dann hier auch abrufen, da drüben bei dir. Oder?
Nee, nee, nee. Machen wir nach der Sendung.
Also nicht erwarten, dass direkt die Antworten heute noch in der Sendung kommen, das ist ja wichtig. Wir hatten neulich ein paar Mails, wo jemand gesagt hat, ihr gebt ja gar keine Antworten auf eure Mails, jetzt schreibt doch mal zurück, das wird in der Sendung nicht passieren. Entschuldigung soweit, aber wir haben ja Telefon. 0331 77 97 110 die Nummer. Benny, eine Frage noch und zwar Interaktion. Also zum Beispiel, Fritz macht ja auch relativ viel Talk. Ist das was, was Radio auch ausmacht für dich oder eher die Musik? Weil Musik ist sowas, das wird immer ganz, ganz hoch gehalten. Radio zeichnet sich durch Musik aus, alles andere ist sekundär. Es gibt Leute, die sowas sagen. Wie wichtig ist da der Anteil von dem und der Anteil von dem anderen für dich?
Also gerade deshalb höre ich ja Fritz, weil es einfach mal was anderes ist. Auf den ganzen anderen Radiosendern hört man immer nur Musik, Musik, Musik und das ist einfach mal stinklangweilig. Und ich habe einfach mal nach was gesucht, wo man auch selber sich aktiv beteiligen kann, mitreden kann. Und das kann man kaum bei anderen Radiosendungen. Und deshalb bin ich einfach begeisterter Fritz-Hörer, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen.
Ach, das läuft rein. Dann nehmen wir das einfach mal so mit. Benni und vielen Dank für den Anruf. Und der Tom aus Erkner ist dran. Hallo Tom. David, Radio für dich, das Tolle am Radio.
Und ist denn Radio auch Unterhaltung, oder ist das jetzt nur Information?
Wenn man nach Hause kommt, wenn sich stresst, dann will man noch kurz, wenn was, ein Tag passiert ist, dann will man aber auch Entspannung haben.
Und das ist es für dich, also das ist die optimale Mischung. Da würdest du doch nicht zum Fernseher greifen oder dir ein Video reintun von einem Film, den du vielleicht schon zweimal gesehen hast, der dich deswegen nicht so aufregt. Radio ist genau das, was diese Lücke füllt.
Genau, also Entspannung pur. Manchmal mache ich auch drei Sachen, die eigentlich natürliche Aufgaben machen, noch mir aus dem Internet etwas rausziehen, dann kommt ein Anruf und dann sage ich mal, ich rufe sie doch nochmal an, mache Computer aus und mache einfach Radio kurz.
Und das, was du jetzt gemacht hast, Anrufen, streng dich das dann quasi an, lässt dich das aus diesem Radio entspannen, höher Rhythmus raus irgendwie? Oder ist das, was du gern machst? Also hast du auch lustig da irgendwie einzubringen, so in die Interaktion mit dem Radio zu treten?
Ja genau, das war mein Vorredner, der sagte, kann ich nur voll mit zustimmen. Das ist nicht einfach, Klasse, wo man sich selbst mit beteiligen kann. Wenn man jetzt irgendeinem Talk ist, zum Beispiel im Boilband oder Blumen, wenn man jetzt hört, die Norde hat ein Miscrete, dann ruft man an und tut es mit Begradigen gleich.
Aber trotzdem ist es ja nicht der Trend. Das, was wir hier machen, ist ja jetzt nicht das teuerste, was man sich vorstellen kann beim Radio. Das Geld wird für andere Sachen bezahlt bei so einem Sender. Deswegen ist es ja merkwürdig, warum machen das nicht alle? Weil es scheint ja vielen Leuten zu gefallen. Und das rufen ja heute Abend auch schon viele Leute an, wie ich das hier sehen kann zu diesem Thema. Warum glaubst du, warum ist das nicht so wirklich populär? Weil das, was du beim normalen Radio machen kannst, was du überall findest, sind Gewinnspiele. Ist eine QA schwarz-weiß oder B lila? Und dann kannst du irgendwie ein Auto gewinnen oder du kommst in den Topf dafür. Warum ist das dann deiner Meinung nach nicht so beliebt?
Aber zum Beispiel bei deinen Eltern, könntest du dir vorstellen, dass sie auch beim Radio anrufen? Also jetzt nicht vielleicht bei Fritz, sondern bei einem Radiosender, was ihrem Geschmack mehr entspricht. Wenn die auch so eine Form von Talk oder Interaktion hätten, könntest du dir vorstellen, dass sie da auch dann so anrufen würden? Oder ist das jetzt eine Sache mit dem Anrufen, was jetzt eher was für die junge Generation ist?
80er, weil 80 Jahre Radio, da müsste er eigentlich dabei sein. Was könnte man deiner Meinung nach noch verbessern? Ich glaube, das ist etwas, da werden wir heute Abend wahrscheinlich keine große Antwort drauf kriegen. Radio scheint relativ gut akzeptiert zu sein, so wie es ist.
Vielleicht sind noch alle einfach nur zu eingefahren. Vielleicht hat sich einfach noch niemand Gedanken darüber gemacht, was noch besser sein könnte.
Vielleicht kriegen wir eine Antwort vom Tom. Jetzt sind wir wieder ganz nah, pass auf.
Max spielt halt ganz viel mit den Reglern rum.
Was du am Radio besser machen würdest, bzw. es geht jetzt nicht unbedingt nur darum, vielleicht sollte man die Frage auch mal ein bisschen ausformulieren. Es geht jetzt nicht unbedingt darum, ich möchte mehr Sport hören oder ich möchte irgendwie mehr Musik hören oder sowas, sondern auch was, was in Richtung Zukunft geht. Vielleicht sollte man das für den Hinterkopf schon mal haben, für alle anderen, die anrufen möchten. Radio on demand, wir hatten schon dieses On-Demand-Prinzip, dass man sich zum Beispiel seine eigene Playlist zusammenstellen kann. Im Internet wird das immer wieder versucht. Du hast irgendein Reggae-Radio, da möchte ich gerne das und das und das hören. Sowas könnte man mit Content ja irgendwann auch mal probieren.
Also auch personalisiertes Radio im Sinne von, dass du auch Werbespots personalisiert kriegst, weil das Ganze muss ja auch finanzieren, so eine Geschichte. Dass du im Prinzip so ein persönliches Profil hast, wo du sagen kannst, ich hätte gerne Musik aus den Bereichen, Informationen aus den Bereichen und Werbung hätte ich gerne aus den Bereichen.
So was, kannst du dir das vorstellen, dass man da noch was verbessern könnte oder eher nicht?
Werbung kann wegfallen von mir aus.
Werbung kann wegfallen, großartig. Damit finanziert man sich natürlich.
Na gut, für euch und für uns hören, das ist mal ein bisschen blöd, wenn da jetzt eine Obi-Werbung kommt.
Na, du wirst lachen. Ich habe ein paar Kollegen, denen würdest du das nicht ansehen, aber wenn Obi oder, warte, wer ist das andere? Das ist, glaube ich, Hornbach. Es gibt immer was zu tun. Wenn der Hornbach-Katalog bei uns in der Redaktion liegt, da wird sich drum gerissen. Oh, der neue 22er-Hexler, den stelle ich mir in den Garten. Unglaublich. Es gibt tatsächlich Leute, die finden das toll.
Wobei es natürlich auch eine Frage ist, ob du ein Privatradio hörst oder ein öffentlich-rechtliches. Da ist ja nur die Frage der Finanzierung. Öffentlich-rechtlich finanziert sich ja nur über die Gebühren, über die Fernseh- und Rundfunkgebühren. Da wird das Geld einfach anders erhoben. Beim Privatradio ist es ja so, die Werbespots müssen ja auch bezahlt werden. Die bezahlst du dann im Prinzip nächsten Tag im Supermarkt beim Einkauf mit, über den Werbeetal der Firma. Die Rundfunkgebühren bezahlst du direkt. Insofern ist das ein anderer Weg. Ich denke, das ist eine große Extra-Diskussion, die wir vielleicht heute Abend...
Finanzierung meinst du?
Ja, Finanzierung schon. Aber ob man das privat finanzierte oder gebührenfinanzierte Modell gut findet, da gibt es auch gerade wieder ein bisschen Diskussionen. Da gab es wieder eine heiße Schlammschlacht vor ein paar Tagen. Und ich denke, das ist noch mal ein extra ziemlich großes Thema.
Können wir ja gucken. Wenn wir heute Abend dazu kommen, zu späterer Stunde, können wir das ja auf jeden Fall nochmal anreißen. Vielen Dank für den Anruf.
Wir versuchen es.
Und bleibt gut weiterhin radiobegeistert. Wir finden das prima.
Ich muss ja schon nochmal kurz lästern. Die GEZ, die Gebühren-Einzug-Zentrale, hat natürlich auch am letzten Freitag einen Big Brother-Award bekommen. Der Big Brother-Award ist ein Preis für einen negativen Preis für Firmen und Institutionen, die sich besonders um die Verletzung der Privatsphäre und des Datenschutzes verdient gemacht haben. Und wird dann vergeben an Firmen wie zum Beispiel Microsoft oder an die Deutsche Post.
Also für alle, die jetzt nur Preise kennen, wenn irgendwelche breitkreuzigen Schwimmer so eine Bronzemedaille umgehegt bekommen, ist nichts Positives, was da vergeben wurde. Und wieso genau? Was gibt es denn da für Venture und Venture? Ich möchte ja auch ein bisschen was hören.
Ja, also das Problem bei der Gebühren-Einzugszentrale ist einfach, dass sie sich benehmen, je nachdem wie es ihnen gerade passt, nämlich entweder als Behörde, als öffentliche Einrichtung oder als Firma, als Privatunternehmen. Wenn es darum geht, Adressen zu beschaffen, nämlich zum Beispiel bei privaten Adresshändlern oder irgendwelche Datenbanken abzugleichen und so eine Sache, dann sind sie dann Privatunternehmen. Weil es dürfen nämlich Behörden nicht so ohne Weiteres, sie dürfen sich nicht aus irgendwelchen dubiosen Datenquellen Adressen beschaffen. Und wenn es darum geht, wenn sie jetzt zum Beispiel die Mail-Daten, also jemand zieht um, dann kriegt er automatisch die GEZ, eine Mitteilung, da ist jemand umgezogen. Und solche Daten dürfen natürlich nicht an Firmen übermittelt werden, sondern nur an Behörden und so. Und in dem Moment, wenn es darum geht, ist sie dann plötzlich wieder eine Behörde.
Also die picken sich sozusagen die Rosinen aus dem Kuchen raus.
Genau.
Und deswegen haben die den Big Brother Award bekommen, weil die das geschickt machen, ja?
Die machen natürlich auch noch ein paar andere lustige Geschichten. Zum Beispiel, dass sie dich anrufen und sich als Meinungsforschungsinstitut ausgeben und dich dann zu deinem Lieblings-Fernsehprogramm befragen. Und dann zwei Tage später ist der Besuch da. Aber sie haben ja gar kein Fernseher angemeldet. Wie kommt denn das sein? Und so kleine nette Geschichten. Aber das ist...
Das ist sehr frech, dass ich um solche Uhrzeiten nie zu Hause bin, wenn die mich anrufen könnten. Prima, prima. Sollte die auch nicht. Einfach mit solchen Meinungsforschungsleuten gar nicht sprechen. Gar nicht mitreden. Juti, wir reden gleich weiter. Wir werden heute Abend auch ein paar Leute interviewen, auch zum Thema Piratenradio zum Beispiel. Das machen wir wahrscheinlich gleich mal. Jetzt gibt es aber erst mal die Nachrichten auf Fritz.
Wenn Fritz in Fürstenwalde, dann 101, 5.
22.30 Uhr. Teilweise kann es ein bisschen Regen geben. In der Nacht sinken die Temperaturen auf 4 bis 1 Grad. Morgen ist es weiterhin ziemlich wolkig und besonders am Vormittag regnet es. Die Temperaturen steigen maximal auf 10 Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit Mario Bartsch.
Der frühere Bundesfinanzminister Lafontaine wird 2004 nicht als SPD-Spitzenkandidat bei der Landtagswahl im Saarland antreten. Stattdessen soll SPD-Landeschef Maas Herausforderer von Ministerpräsident Müller werden. In den letzten Wochen hatte es Spekulationen über ein Comeback Lafontaines gegeben. Nach dem Bombenanschlag auf sein Gebäude in Bagdad zieht das internationale Komitee vom Roten Kreuz einen Teil seiner Mitarbeiter aus dem Irak ab. Die Zahl der nicht-irakischen Helfer werde reduziert, sagte ein Sprecher. Auch die Hilfsorganisation Ärzte ohne Grenzen holt einen Teil seines Personals zurück. Der US-Investor Philipp Anschutz bekommt offenbar rund eine Million Euro vom Berliner Senat für sein Großhallenprojekt am Ostbahnhof. Das schreibt die Berliner Zeitung unter Berufung auf Stadtentwicklung Senator Strider. Bislang hatte der Senat stets betont, dass Anschutz keine Zuschüsse aus der Landesklasse für das Projekt erhalte. Ein ziviler Testjet ist in der Nähe von Brannenburg in Oberbayern abgestürzt. Der Alpha-Jet bohrte sich auf einem Feld in den Boden. Das Schicksal der beiden Besatzungsmitglieder ist noch unklar. Die Polizei vermutet aber, dass sie ums Leben gekommen sind. Und zum Sport in der zweiten Runde des DFB-Pokals ist Union Berlin ausgeschieden. Die Berliner verloren gegen Bayer Leverkusen mit 0 zu 5. Eine Runde weiter sind neben Leverkusen auch Braunschweig, der HSV, Werder Bremen, der SC Freiburg, Borussia München, Glattbach und Hoffenheim. Unterverkehr auf Fritz mit drei Meldungen A10 südlicher Berliner Ringrich. Potsdam Richtung Schönefelder Kreuz. Zwischen Ferch und Potsdam Süd gibt es wegen Brückenarbeiten zwei gesperrte Spuren. A10 Werder Richtung Hafenland zwischen Leest und Potsdam Nord. Störung durch Defekt des Fahrzeug auf dem rechten Fahrstreifen. Und A111 Berlin-Charlottenburg Richtung Oranienburg der Tunnelflughafen Tegel. Dort ist wegen Instandhaltungsarbeiten der rechten Fahrstreifen gesperrt. Ansonsten gute Fahrt.
Wünsch dir dein Stück vom Glück.
Hallo, ich bin Jens. Und für mich wäre Glück oder mein größter Traum mal Bruce Willis zu treffen.
Ruf den Fritz-Glücksbeantworter an.
Und wünsch dir dein Stück vom Glück.
0331 für Potsdam, 70 97 125.
Wir werden versuchen, deinen Glückswunsch zu erfüllen.
Fritz, die Wochen des Glücks.
Das Glück auf Fritz wird freundlich unterstützt von www.LottoBrandenburg.de. Das Original für Gewinne und Glück. Und im Radio? Glück, Glück.
Der man hat den Groove in der Rose. DJ Cole aus Wien ist heute angestellt beim Chaosradio den letzten Mittwoch im Monat auf Fritz. Wir haben noch zweieinhalb Stunden Talkzeit hier. Und gegenüber von mir sitzt der Frank Rosengard, auch vom CCC. Mein Name ist Max von Malotki. Und wir gehen heute Abend auf das Thema ab 80 Jahre Radio. 1960 ging das erste sogenannte Offshore-Radio-Aufsendung. In vielen Staaten haben damals die Regierungen nämlich keine Lizenzen für private Radios in der Vergangenheit. Privaten Rundfunk gibt es in Deutschland erst seit 1984. Also halte man sich damit aus, dass die Sendeanlage auf, und jetzt kommt es, ein Schiff montiert wurde und damit außerhalb des Hoheitsgebietes gefahren ist. Die Antennen waren aber landswärts gerichtet, ist klar, bringt ja nix für die Fische, sind wir ja loof. Und so entwickelte sich in den 70er Jahren so eine regelrechte Massenbewegung der freien Radios auf See.
Genau, und da sind ganz besonders bekannt Radio Veronica und Radio London. Haben also eine ziemlich aufregende Geschichte hinter sich und bemühen sich heute aber, um eher regulierten und schon fast kommerziellen Umfeld Fuß zu fassen. Die Regierungen der Länder versuchten damals mit Anti-Radio-Piraten-Gesetzen die ungenehmigten Seesender zu stoppen. Man hat nämlich einfach die Werbekunden wegen Unterstützung angeklagt. Die wollten ja also praktisch diese Sender dann Sponsoren, die haben ja gesagt, okay, wir schalten bei euch Werbung. Aber das Problem war, dass einfach diese Gelder konnten da nicht ankommen, weil sie einfach die Sender, die die Firmen angeklagt haben, dann vor Gericht gezerrt haben, die diese Piraten-Sender unterstützt haben. Über diesen Umweg haben sie es dann auch geschafft, diese Seeradios im Prinzip mundtot zu machen.
Deswegen hat Pi-Radio auch kein eigenes Schiff, könnte man so sagen.
Ja, in Berlin haben nämlich auch Piraten-Radios schon eine ganz ansehnliche Geschichte hinter sich und mit einem Menschen, der da schon auch ein bisschen was mit zu tun hat, der ist jetzt am Telefon, nämlich der Jens Gröger von Pi-Radio. Hallo.
Ja hallo, guten Abend.
Wofür steht das Pi bei euch? Ist das eine Abkürzung für Piraten-Radio?
Nee, Pi ist die unberechenbare Konstante und das ist auch das Prinzip von Pi-Radio, dass es nämlich immer dort auftaucht, wo es nicht erwartet wurde. Es ist schon oft totgesagt worden, es gibt es aber immer noch.
Bis zu wievielten Nachkommastellen kannst du?
Ich kann nur vier Nachkommastellen, aber es ist ja auch nicht unsere Aufgabe, uns aufzuspüren oder uns zu ergründen, sondern es ist die Aufgabe von anderen. Pi-Radio ist eigentlich die legale Nachfolgeorganisation von Radio Prenzlauer Berg. Wir haben als Radio Prenzlauer Berg festgestellt, das zehn Minuten zu senden und dann wieder die Sendeanlage einzupacken, aus Angst vorm Peilwagen, dass das nicht bringt. Deshalb haben wir als Pi-Radio einen legalen Verein gegründet, wo wir versucht haben, das Radio zu legalisieren. Das ist dann eine lange Odyssee, die bis heute zur Radiokampagne mündet. Aber da können wir jetzt in Ruhe drüber sprechen.
Jetzt müssen wir einfach mal einen Grundstein legen für diejenigen, die sich jetzt überhaupt nicht vorstellen, warum es bei illegalem Radio überhaupt gehen kann und was ein Peilwagen ist. Da kannst du ja vielleicht mal ein bisschen was erzählen, weil was ist das für ein Radiosender, der nur zehn Minuten am Tag sendet, das kriegt doch, würde jetzt der Laie wahrscheinlich sagen, überhaupt keiner mit. Was ist denn dann überhaupt illegales Radio?
Das Verblüffende an Radio ist ja, dass es ein ganz einfaches Medium ist. Also ein Radiosender zu bauen ist wesentlich einfacher als ein Radioempfänger zu bauen. Das heißt, jeder kann im Prinzip, der ein bisschen technischen Sachverstand hat, ein Sender zusammenbauen und anfangen zu senden. Und weil es so einfach ist, sind dann die Gesetze auch entsprechend streng, die das Radiosenden verbieten, nämlich bis vor kurzem galt noch das Fernmeldeanlagengesetz, was 1936 geschaffen wurde und da kann man sich ja vorstellen, das sah dann Gefängnisstrafen für Senden vor. Und der Verwalter dieses Äthos des Frequenzraumes ist ja die Telekom und hat auch Interesse daran, den Raum sauber zu halten, weil sie vermieten nämlich die Sender für ein horrendes Geld. Und deshalb ist natürlich beides, also sowohl das zu senden ohne Lizenz ist natürlich gefährlich, weil die Revolution ausgerufen werden kann. Und zum anderen ist es natürlich für die Post einfach oder für die Telekom einfach ein Verlust an Einkommen, wenn dort illegal gesendet wird.
Aber es sind so ein kleiner Piratensender, der irgendwo auf dem Dach steht und mal zehn Minuten sendet, denn wirklich auch eine Gefahr, also eine wirtschaftliche Gefahr für die Telekom zum Beispiel schon?
Also wenn tatsächlich in Berlin Londoner Zustände herrschen würden, dass nämlich 20 Piratensender sich das ganze Frequenzband untereinander aufgeteilt haben, dann würde die Telekom tatsächlich keinen Sender mehr vermieten können. Aber so preußisch-deutsch, wie man ist in Deutschland, ist man da nicht so locker drauf, sondern da hält man sich schon sehr an Gesetze. Aber es ist jetzt auch gar nicht mehr so illegal, Piratensender zu betreiben. Jetzt gilt nämlich eben dieses Telekommunikationsgesetz seit ein paar Jahren und es sieht nicht mehr Gefängnisstrafen für Senden vor, sondern es ist nur noch eine Ordnungswidrigkeit. Also im Prinzip muss man nur noch ein Ordnungsgeld bezahlen und es macht das Ganze natürlich viel entspannter.
So wie falsch parken ungefähr, ne?
Wie falsch parken, genau. Und man kann natürlich auch nicht einfach Wohnungen durchsuchen oder was jetzt dabei Radio Veronica beschrieben wurde, andere Leute wegen Beteiligung an einer Straftat oder sowas anklagen, geht einfach nicht bei einer Ordnungswidrigkeit. Es gibt keine gemeinschaftliche Ordnungswidrigkeit. Deshalb kann man unter den jetzigen gesetzlichen Rahmenbedingungen ohne Weiteres ein öffentliches Studio betreiben und dann einen illegalen Sender, den irgendjemand anderes verantworten muss, man selber aber nicht.
Und wie schnell geht so was, weil du hast gesagt, nur 10 Minuten senden und dann war der Peilwagen da. Sind die da wirklich so schnell gewesen, auch damals, dass die euch innerhalb von, was weiß ich, 25 Minuten gekascht haben, sind die da so auf dem Kiviv?
Im Prinzip ja, das sind Fahrzeiten, die längste Zeit, von zwei Punkten in Berlin muss man mit der Peilantenne peilen, dann hat man so den Häuserblock raus, fährt dann mit dem Auto vor und packt dann die Handpeilgeräte aus und so wurde zum Beispiel bei Twin FM, die in so einem Club in der Brunnenstraße ihr Radio betrieben haben, wurde dann direkt hineinspaziert in die Party, die da gelaufen ist, mit den Peilgeräten und der Senderbeschlag, die die Party aufgelöst haben und so weiter. Das dauert tatsächlich nur 20 Minuten, deshalb ist es auch ein bisschen ungünstig als Piratensender, es ist immer so ein Katz-Maus-Spiel oder man macht eben diese Londoner-Methode, die es auch noch gibt, dass man mehrere Sender hat, die man dann so Multitasking-mäßig umschaltet.
Kannst du das noch mal ein bisschen erzählen? Also es gab ja damals irgendwie auch Radio Westfernsehen, was vermutlich mal eher so ein politisch motiviertes Radio war und...
Okay, Pi-Radio ist wie gesagt ein legaler Verein. Wir haben uns darauf verlegt, andere Leute zu beraten, wie man Piraten-Sender betreibt. Also wir haben auch selber versucht, ein legales, freies Radio in Berlin zu gründen und es auch finanziert zu kriegen. Es ist alles gescheitert. Weshalb wir uns jetzt darauf verlegen, Workshops anzubieten, wie ein Piraten-Sender zusammenbastelt. Und unter anderem haben wir Radio Westfernsehen unterstützt dabei, seine Sendung zu machen. Das waren 99 und 2000. Also so ungefähr ein Jahr lang haben die gesendet. Aus dem Tacheles, da gibt es so einen Aufzugsturm, der so über die Stadt ragt. Aus diesem Turm hat Radio Westfernsehen gesendet. Ein politisches Programm, jetzt so ungefähr das Kontrastprogramm zur Twin FM, die immer Party und Musik und so weiter gesendet haben, war natürlich dieses politische Programm wesentlich unbeliebter. Deshalb wurden dann ziemlich bald die Peilwägen rausgeschickt. Was war deine Frage nochmal?
Ich wollte darauf hinaus, dass du mal die Situation beschreibst, wie ist es mit so einem Sender auf dem Dach? Wie muss ich mir diese Installationen vorstellen? Was muss ich hoch aufs Dach tragen und wie funktioniert das praktisch?
Ja, unpraktisch ist es, wenn man es wie Radio Westfernsehen macht, den Sender fest zu installieren und dann regelmäßig von dem Punkt aus senden, dann spart man sich nämlich die 20 Minuten. Dann weiß man schon, wo der Sender steht und muss dann nur noch kommen, um zu schauen, wer da rumläuft, wer den Sender betreibt. Praktischer ist es da schon, den Sender tatsächlich transportabel zu haben. Das macht dann aber auch nicht so viel Spaß. Also man hat den Sender im Rucksack, stellt ihn auf und hat dann meinst wegen einen Walkman dabei oder einen CD-Spieler, wo man dann die vorproduzierte Sendung abspielt. Es macht natürlich wesentlich weniger Spaß als in einem richtigen Studio, wo man anrufen kann, wo man mitdiskutieren kann, wo Besucher empfangen werden können und so weiter.
Und ist dieses Radiomachen, gibt es ja noch irgendwie dieses Prickeln, da irgendwo auf dem Dach zu steigen, Sender zu machen, oder ist das für dich eher so die Möglichkeit, auch einfach unabhängig Radioprogrammen machen zu können? Oder für die Leute, die jetzt zu euch kommen, haben die noch diese Abenteuerlust dabei oder geht es wirklich darum, dass sie einfach ihr Programm dann durchziehen wollen?
Ja, im Prinzip teilt sich das auf in Technikfreunde oder in Abenteuerfreunde und welche, die wirklich ein inhaltliches Programm machen wollen und das widerspricht sich natürlich auch, weil du natürlich als Piratensende einigermaßen konspirativ arbeiten musst. Das heißt, du kannst eben nicht öffentlich rumlaufen, sagen, ich mache nächsten Dienstag diese Piratensendung, sondern du musst dich da immer verdeckt halten. Deshalb gibt es eben zwei Fraktionen, die einen, die ein freies Radio betreiben wollen und die anderen, die sagen, uns dauert es zu lange, den Weg durch die Institution, wir machen lieber gleich Piratensendungen und das muss natürlich Spaß machen. Also wenn es keinen Spaß macht, auf den Dächern rumzuklettern oder irgendwelche Schaltungen zusammenzulöten oder so, dann sollte man es besser bleiben lassen.
Hat sich damit die Möglichkeiten des Internet eigentlich auch was geändert, weil dieses freie Broadcasting ist, wenn man ein bisschen technisch versiert ist im Internet, natürlich auch relativ schwer rückzuverfolgen, dass man dann sagt, wir gehen auf dieses Medium, weil da haben wir auch die Chance, an einem Platz erreichbar zu sein, ist eigentlich viel einfacher. Ist das eine Alternative geworden oder eher nicht?
Also zum Empfangen ist es keine Alternative, dass man jetzt Livestreams aussendet und erwartet, dass die Leute am Rechner sitzen und bei tickendem Gebührenzähler da ein Radio empfangen. Aber tatsächlich zum Senden ist es eine Alternative, dass man nämlich ein fettes Studio hat, Internet Livestream macht. Radio Westland sehen hat es teilweise auch gemacht. Der anderswo von irgendwelchen Desperado rausgezogen wird und auf Antenne gepackt wird, da kann man dann ja selber auch nichts dafür und das wollte man ja in Wirklichkeit auch gar nicht. Und es hat aber den Vorteil, dass es auch flächendeckend, also in der ganzen Stadt oder auch in anderen Städten abgestrahlt werden kann mit kleinen Sendern. Also das ist durchaus ein Vorteil der Technik und es geht natürlich noch weiter, wenn man die technischen Varianten weiterspinnen will. Gerade ist zum Beispiel in Berlin jemand dran, solche Funknetze aufzubauen, dass ein Livestream über so ein Computer-Funknetz geschickt wird und an unterschiedlichen Stellen mit winzigen Sendern abgestrahlt wird. Das ist natürlich auch eine tolle Möglichkeit, einfach dieses Sendesignal zu entzerren und deshalb auch die Anpeilbarkeit natürlich deutlich zu erschweren.
Wofür braucht man das überhaupt? Das ist ja eine Grundsatzfrage. In Berlin ist der härteste Radiomarkt überhaupt. Es gibt nirgendwo so viele Sender wie in Berlin und Umgebung. Wofür braucht man da noch so ein Piratenradio, was sowieso alle 10 Minuten umziehen muss, wenn ich jetzt mal so asimäßig fragen darf.
Und es gibt einen offenen Kanal dazu auch noch. Also es gibt ja in Berlin tatsächlich eine Möglichkeit, einfach da gehe ich hin. Sagen wir, ich mache jetzt hier irgendwie eine Stunde Radio, einmal im Monat oder wie auch immer. Also was ist denn noch?
Ja, also ich meine die 27 Radioprogramme, die müssen wir bloß mal durchswitchen und dann kriegt man mit. Dann kann man dann ziemlich viele von wegstreichen. Da bleiben vielleicht noch zwei, drei übrig, die man hören kann. Und die sind dann öffentlich-rechtliche Radios, die natürlich einen ganz anderen Versorgungsauftrag haben, als so ein Piraten-Sender oder so ein freies Radio leisten kann, nämlich einfach Subkultur, unbekannte Labels zu spielen, irgendwelchen Kiez-Literaten einen Forum zu geben, irgendwelchen Theaterleuten die Möglichkeit geben, sich zu präsentieren. Das kann natürlich so ein öffentlich-rechtliches Radio nicht, was ja dem irgendwelchen Rundfunkgeräten unterliegt, die dann wieder ihre Partei-Interessen haben. Also öffentlich-rechtliches Radio hat ja einen Bildungsauftrag. Das hat natürlich ein freies Radio nicht, sondern das ist tatsächlich die Kunst für die Kunst.
Wie ist es mit dem offenen Kanal? Wäre das eine Alternative?
Also bis vor kurzem hat der offene Kanal ja nur im Kabel gesendet und dann ist der offene Kanal natürlich auch eine sehr starre Angelegenheit. Da kann ich mich als Einzelperson anmelden und kann als Einzelperson eine Sendung gestalten und so sind sie dann auch die Sendung hintereinander irgendwie wahllos, irgendwelche Individuen, die sich selbst darstellen wollen. Ich habe wenig Möglichkeit, eine regelmäßige Sendung zu machen und ich habe als auch höher wenig Gelegenheit gezielt auf Sendungen zuzugreifen, weil die eben wahllos irgendwann kommen. Und dann ist es natürlich im Kabel. Jetzt hat der offene Kanal neuerdings mit dem Mischkanal irgendwie zwei, drei Stunden am Tag auf Antenne. Da wird es dann schon spannender, aber ich zum Beispiel kann es hier überhaupt gar nicht empfangen und viele andere Leute auch nicht, weil das so ein ausrangierter Sender von Jam FM, glaube ich, ist, der nur irgendwie davor Potsdam oder so abstrahlt. Aber normale Leute können den, glaube ich, gar nicht empfangen.
Du bist natürlich jetzt jemand, den wir auch mal gerne fragen möchten, was wünscht du dir vom Radio? Was möchtest du anders haben? Das haben wir schon ein paar Mal gefragt heute und die meisten sind eigentlich relativ zufrieden mit dem, was sie bekommen, weil sie auch natürlich eine relativ hohe Sender-Auswahl haben. Aber was würdest du anders machen? Was du ja auch anders gemacht hast, wenn du gerade ein Radio gemacht hast, aber was würdest du anders machen?
Also zum einen ist das der Witz am Radio, dass das Radio sowohl zum Hören an, dass der Empfänger gleichzeitig ein Sender werden kann, dass da die Transparenz unheimlich vorhanden ist. Also im Prinzip müsste ich jedem Hörer die Möglichkeit geben, auch ans Mikro zu können und zwar nicht, indem ich lustige Gewinnspielchen mache und natürlich auch nicht, indem ich in so einer Zwangssituation, also ich meine, diese Talksendungen bei euch abends haben ja schon den Charakter, die Leute möglichst viel zu Wort kommen zu lassen, aber es ist eben was anderes, wenn ich den Leuten wirklich die Verantwortung übergebe, eine Sendung zu machen. Und in dem freien Radio, ich habe in Freiburg bei Radio Dreieckland mitgearbeitet, da gibt es eben Redaktionen, wo du sofort reingehen kannst. Also wenn du Lust hast, bei der schwulen Redaktion mitzumachen oder so was, kannst du dahin gehen und kannst mitmachen. Die Leute zeigen dir, wie es geht und du kannst dann erstmal deinen 5-Minuten-Beitrag machen und so weiter, dich da reinarbeiten. Das hat natürlich eine unheimliche Medienkompetenz, die dahinter steckt, also dass du nicht nur konsumierst das Radio, sondern auch einfach selber machen kannst. Und dadurch kommen natürlich noch ganz andere Sachen auf den Äther zu hören, als jetzt diese ganzen independenten Labels und Bands, die ihre selber gebrannten Platten haben und so weiter, können dann plötzlich auf Radio erscheinen, die jetzt noch nicht erscheinen.
Ist natürlich die Frage, hat dieser jahrelange Entzug, den die Medien den Leuten zugemutet haben, die Leute inkompetent gemacht in dem Bereich? Oder würdest du dir vorstellen, dass die Leute, wenn man sie dazu erzieht, was man ja eigentlich machen müsste, dann irgendwann wieder geil darauf sind? Weil ich glaube nicht, dass die meisten einfach Verantwortung übernehmen wollen. Ich glaube, die würden mal sagen, ganz problemisch, die meisten sind ganz zufrieden damit, dass sie vielleicht höchstens zu ihrer Steuererklärung Verantwortung tragen müssen.
Nee, also da kann ich tatsächlich auch jetzt beobachten, in acht Jahren bemühen, in Berlin ein freies Radio zu installieren, dass die Bereitschaft, da wirklich Energie rein zu hängen, immer mehr abnimmt und dass die Leute tatsächlich schon so zugeballert sind, Konsum, gesellschaftsmäßig. Aber ich meine, es kann sich ja ändern. Also ich kann auf der einen Seite nicht klagen darüber, dass die Leute politikverdrossen sind, auf der anderen Seite ihnen überhaupt keine Handlungsmöglichkeiten geben. Also vielleicht hat ja auch die Politik oder, was hatte ich, die Bildung einen Auftrag, die Leute medienkompetenter zu machen.
Ja, aber das ist, ich meine, es ist super schwierig. Also wenn man solche Sendungen sieht, also was, was kommt momentan auch im Fernsehen, das ist ja eine Sache. Also man kann ja jetzt nicht nur sagen, nur was das Radio macht, nur was das Fernsehen macht, nur was das Internet macht. Aber wenn du dir anguckst, was momentan so Erfolg hat, da kriegst doch du wahrscheinlich den doppelten Schweißfilm hinten auf dem Rücken vor lauter Angst, oder?
Ich muss sagen, Radio höre ich schon lange nicht mehr. Und ja, ich meine, öffentlich-rechtliche Anstalten machen immer noch ganz nette Sachen, muss man sagen. Aber ich meine, das Prinzip des freien Radios ist natürlich nicht kommerziell unabhängig zu sein. Und in der Tat, wenn ich jetzt, wenn ich irgendwelche kommerziellen Fernsehsender schaue, dann stört mich allein schon die Werbung, die ich inzwischen drin immer tragen muss. Muss ich im freien Radio zum Glück nicht.
Ganz kurz, was genau ist die Radiokampagne, die es in Berlin gibt? Es gibt ja auch www.radio-kampagne.de. Und wofür setzt ihr euch da ein?
Genau, also P-Radio hat die Radiokampagne mit initiiert mit einigen anderen Gruppen, die auch Interesse dran haben, freies Radio zu machen. Freies Radio, noch mal vorweg, ist ein Radio, was selbst organisiert ist, also was nicht wie der offene Kanal eine Anstalt des öffentlichen Rechts ist, wo es keine Chefredaktion gibt, sondern das Radio ist selbst organisiert von den Leuten, die es machen. Es ist offen im Zugang und es ist nicht kommerziell, das freie Radio. Und in vielen anderen Bundesländern, elf anderen Bundesländern gibt es freie Radio, selbstverständlich, also in Hamburg, FSK, oder in Kassel, oder in Freiburg, oder in Stuttgart, oder in Erfurt und so weiter. Nur in Berlin gibt es eben kein freies Radio und es ist eigentlich ein Skandal, dass man in Berlin den Bürgerinnen nicht zutraut, dass sie in der Lage sind, ein Radio selber zu gestalten. Und die Radiokampagne setzt sich dafür ein, dass das Landesmediengesetz geändert wird. Die Medien sind ja Landesangelegenheit. Das heißt, es gibt so ein Bundesgesetz, was freie Radios vorsieht, was auch Gelder für freie Radios aus den GEZ, aus den Rundfunkgebühren vorsieht. Nur der Landesgesetzgeber hat es nicht für notig gefunden, um das in Landesrecht umzusetzen, sondern er hat ja hier seinen offenen Kanal und es war es dann auch. Und die Arbeit der Radiokampagne ist eben, die Politiker, die Parlamente zu drängen, dieses Landesmediengesetz zu ändern. Und das ist ganz schön bei Berlin und Brandenburg, dass sie sich immer rausreden können. Wir würden ja gerne finden, das ist auch ganz toll, aber Brandenburg hindert uns dran und die Brandenburger argumentieren sich genauso andersrum.
Aber gäbe es denn nur einen, also das Ziel, den einen Radio zu haben, ein freies Radio, oder könnte es auch mehrere geben? Also ich kann ja, also wenn da halt, naja, da etabliert sich ja schon irgendwie so eine Gruppe, die denn dieses Radio auch macht. Also es muss ja irgendwie, sagst du, also es hat zwar keine Strukturen, aber da müssen ja schon irgendwie Leute sein, die da auch eine gewisse Kontinuität so an den Tag legen. Sonst wird das nichts, sonst zerläuft es einfach, behaupte ich mal so. Dann gibt es doch aber schon auch so ein festes Grüppchen, die vielleicht auch eine gewisse Richtung dem Ganzen geben. Also politisch oder kulturelle Richtung, wie auch immer. Und dann sagen halt andere, naja, wir wollen aber irgendwie ein anderes freies Radio machen. Also ich meine, so gefragt, wo kommt man dahin denn? 20 freie Radios in Berlin?
Im Prinzip hätte ich da nichts dagegen, dass es 10 freie Radios geben würde, aber auf der anderen Seite hat es natürlich Strukturen. Also die Strukturen sehen so aus, dass es zum Beispiel Redaktionen, also wenn ich das jetzt nach Redaktionen ordne, dass es Redaktionen gibt und die Redaktionen, die haben dann eben einmal in der Woche oder so eine gemeinsame Redaktionskonferenz, wo sie die Sachen, die das Gesamtradio betreffen, diskutieren und abstimmen. Und das funktioniert dann halt im Zweifelsfall nach einem demokratischen Prinzip, dass die, die in der Mehrheit sind, dann sagen können, ob jetzt die Sendezeit von irgendwelchem, welcher einen Gruppe ausgeweitet wird oder was. Aber klar, in einer gewissen Weise wird es immer dominiert werden, aber auf der anderen Seite ist es ja auch offen, also alle Leute, die reinkommen, können auch mitdiskutieren, dass es da so wahnsinnige Unterschiede an Interessen geben würde, dass man deshalb unterschiedliche Radios bräuchte, glaube ich nicht unbedingt.
Wenn ihr euch informieren möchtet, wenn ich das jetzt gerade richtig mitbekommen habe, radiokampagne.de wäre direkt die Anlaufstelle, oder Jens?
Genau, www.radio-kampagne.de, da gibt es eine Unterschriftensammlung. Alle Leute, die auch ein freies Radio haben wollen in Berlin, sollen sich da bitte eintragen. Und wenn es dann irgendwelche stattliche Summe erreicht hat, werden wir die Öffentlichkeit so langsam dann überreichen, diese Unterschriftensammlung.
Jens Gröger war das vom P-Radio. Und wir danken ganz, ganz herzlich für das Interview. Das war ein ganz schöner Riem, aber ganz, ganz viele Erkenntnisse, die für die Diskussion des Abends wahrscheinlich sehr förderlich sein werden. So, 0331 77 97 110 ist die Nummer von uns heute Abend. Und ihr könnt mittalken, wenn ihr möchtet. Ich hoffe, der Christoph aus Bayern ist noch am Telefon. Hallo Christoph. Du interessierst dich nämlich auch für freies Radio, beziehungsweise machst freies Radio. Da unten bei euch gibt es das offensichtlich.
Genau, also nicht in Deutschland, sondern ich wohne an der Grenze zu Salzburg. Und da gibt es das, also in Österreich.
Erzähl doch mal ein bisschen.
Ja, also ich mache jedes Mord mal eine Sendung. Und mache das eigentlich, weil ich eben selber Radio-Moderator werden will, eigentlich zur Übung. Also das ist eigentlich der Hauptgrund. Also ich habe mich am Anfang, habe ich mir sehr hohe Ziele gesteckt, habe mir, gleich wollte ich irgendwelche Themen machen und wollte eigentlich am Anfang sowas ähnliches machen, wie Befried, Blue Moon und solche Sachen, also Talk-Themen besprechen. Aber das geht einfach nicht, weil die Hörerzahlen zu wenig ist. Also es ruft keiner an. Man könnte dort, weiß ich nicht, Konzertkarten für Britney Spears verlosen, aber die Leute rufen nicht an. Also es ist wirklich ganz schlimm. Das ist das Problem an der Sache, naja und dann ist es halt ziemlich leihenhaft aufgebaut und die Technik streikt halt ganz oft. Also das sind die zwei Sachen, die ich bemängle, aber ansonsten ist es eine super Möglichkeit eigentlich.
Wobei man ja für Radio nicht viel Technik braucht. Das ist das, was am Radio auch sehr...
Ja klar, aber wenn dann plötzlich der Kopfhörer versagt oder wenn man plötzlich irgendwie, was weiß ich, wenn die CD nicht abgespielt wird oder die mp3, dann ist es halt wahnsinnig störend.
Aber ich glaube schon, dass es auch bei dem, was denn so eine technische Erwartungshaltung angibt, die gibt es genauso wie beim Fernsehen, auch beim Radio. Also du erwartest schon irgendwie, dass alles so wenigstens einigermaßen die gleiche Lautstärke hat, dass irgendwie so Jingles irgendwie ähnlich klingen oder so eine Geschichten. Also es gibt da schon, glaube ich, so eine gewisse Erwartungshaltung, die auch mit einfachen Mitteln, zumindestens von Nicht-Profis, erstmal auch schwierig zu leisten ist.
Ja klar, das ist klar, also es ist auch so. Also ich versuche natürlich immer professionelles Radio zu machen, weil ich möchte ja gerne selber später professionelles Radio machen. Aber es ist nicht unbedingt kommerziell wahnsinnig.
Aber das funktioniert natürlich nicht so ganz.
Also geht von wegen Technik nicht. Also weil eben zum Beispiel, also ganz einfache Sache, zum Beispiel die Playlist, wenn ich einfach Musik, wir haben einfach kein normales Musikprogramm wie bei großen Sendern oder wie bei anderen Sendern, die das irgendwie abspielen und dann von alleine beenden das Lied, sondern wir haben Musikmatch und dann müssen wir automatisch auf Stop drücken und so weiter und das streikt dann wieder und so weiter, also solche Sachen halt.
Also ihr habt einfach nichts, was so professionell aufs Radio ausgelegt ist, sondern irgendwas, was einfach nur abspielt.
Unser Studio besteht aus einem Container und da ist dann das Pult drinnen und ist eigentlich ganz lustig eingerichtet.
Wie ist das bei euch mit den Kosten, die für den Sendbetrieb entstehen? Wer übernimmt die?
Teilweise mit gibt es Beiträge, also 25 Euro im Jahr, das geht eigentlich. Dafür kriegt man natürlich auch Workshops und so weiter, das ist dann schon sehr toll.
Was kostet sowas, nur dass wir mal eine Vorstellung haben, also so ein Jahr senden, wo gehen da die Kosten hin? Weißt du darüber was? Wo die hingehen ist. Was kostet der Container, was kostet Sendeleistung und so?
Ich weiß nur, sie zahlen Spendegelder von der Kirche, von der Stadt werden sie gefördert und eben doch mit Beiträge.
Habt ihr denn dafür inhaltliche Vorgaben, wenn ihr da von den Geldgebern, wie sieht das aus?
Nein, also das ist ja preisradikale, also das Einzige, dass man nicht darf, ist logisch recht radikale Inhalte. Ganz logisch. Aber es gibt halt wirklich Sendungen, da essen die die ganze Zeit nur oder tun halt nur so irgendwie Scheiße labern.
Gut, aber Scheiße labern ist ja gar nicht so das Problematische, also wenn ihr zum Beispiel von der Stadt finanziert werdet und ihr fangt einfach an, konsequent gegen die aktuelle Regierung immer gegenzuhalten und immer rauf und gibt ihnen Saueres und jetzt haben wir noch eine Geschichte rausgeholt. Wie würde sowas dann sein? Würden die das immer noch gut finden?
Also, ich weiß es nicht, also es gibt sicher, es gab vorhin welche, die haben das gemacht, aber es gibt auch Medienrechts-Workshops, die müssen wir auch alle machen.
Gut, aber es gibt ja immer noch, also das mag ja alles rechtlich okay sein, nur aber schon doch auch deutlich politisch.
Aber zum Beispiel, was finden Leute im Radio interessant? Das ist auch eine Frage, die wir heute ein bisschen klären möchten und zwar von hinten durch die Brust ins Auge, weil wir ja festgestellt haben, wenn wir fragen, was findet ihr im Radio interessant, auch ich finde Radio generell interessant. Das ist dann so die Antwort, die da kommt. Aber was finden Leute in bestimmten Jahren interessant und in anderen wiederum nicht? Es gab zum Beispiel in, ich glaube das war, darf mich jetzt nicht vertun, aber ich meine, es war New York, ein Radiosender, wo zwei Typen einen unglaublichen Erfolg damit hatten, weil du gerade gesagt hast, Typen, die einfach nur essen und quatschen. Die Jungs haben sich morgens hingesetzt, haben sich mit Chips und ihrem Frühstück vor den Fernseher gesetzt, Satellitenschüssel, 120 Kanäle, haben sich alles angeguckt, was da war, haben geseppt und haben währenddessen kritisierend darüber geredet, was da im Fernsehen läuft und die haben so hohe Einschaltquoten gehabt, weil die Jungs so, oh Spaghetti-Wästern, ah Terence Hill, herrlich, immer wenn der was sagt, hör mir mal rein, Buff, dann kommt irgendwie ein Stück Terence Hill, dann so, ich find den Typen so geil und die Schuhe, hast du die Schuhe gesehen, Mike? Und dann irgendwie, Mike, ja, geile Leder, Stiefel und das ging halt nur so und das fanden die Leute total geil.
Das hat ja dann schon ein bisschen Show-Effekt, aber teilweise ist es halt bei uns so, also ich versuche natürlich immer, interessante Sendungen zu machen, versuche ich, wie gesagt, mir gelingt es auch oft nicht und mir sind auch ein tausend peinliche Sendungen passiert, wo ich dann plötzlich irgendwie ein Mikrofon offen gelassen habe und gleichzeitig...
Passiert uns auch hier mal.
Ja, also das sowas passiert mir gut jetzt mittlerweile nicht mehr so oft, aber also am Anfang gerade, da war das ziemlich peinlich und oft ziemlich frustrierend, aber eigentlich, es gibt halt Sendungen wirklich, die wirklich guten Antwort haben und es gibt dann wieder welche, die wahnsinnig einfach nur ein Werk geben, nicht vorbereitet und die Leute und die wird sich wirklich keine Ahnung hören. Also es gibt wirklich super Sachen, also es gibt wirklich auch welche, die reden nur die ganze Zeit, totalen Quatsch, aber das ist irgendwie die Wortspiele, die sie machen, die sind einfach genial. Also da kann ich mir gut vorstellen, das könnte auch ins öffentlich-rechtliche Radio mal rein, also eine Stunde zum Beispiel. Also das ist wirklich ganz unterschiedlich.
Warum zeichnest du nicht auf, also warum zeichnest du die Sachen nicht vorher auf?
Weil ich finde, Radi soll einen Live-Charakter haben. Also das ist schon eines der wichtigsten Dinge. Teilweise tun sie natürlich Interviews, Aufzeichnungen oder sonstiges, aber das meiste möchte ich schon live machen und also ich finde, das ist ja das tolle Live einfach. Das ist ja die Live-Charakter, also das ist nicht das Schlimmste, wenn Sender über Nacht zu tun hat, ob sie live sind, aber eigentlich gar nicht live sind, das gibt es ja auch genug.
Ja, gibt es auch immer häufiger. Die Frage ist nur, das was du als Fehler beschreibst, also das was dir so passiert, dass du ein Mikro offen lässt und so, das sind ja genau die Effekte des Livesendens und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, dass bei den reingewaschenen Formaten, die man momentan überall präsentiert bekommt und die es auch immer häufiger, immer stärker so gibt, dass ich es eben ganz genau dann geil finde und dann auch live geil finde, wenn du das Mikrofon offen lässt und es ist natürlich peinlich und vielleicht, wenn du jetzt gerade eine kulturelle Sendung gehabt hast und sagst dann so, boah, ich hab hier gerade gefurzt und hab so einen Fleck auf der Hose, dass das dann nicht so gut kommt, aber Tatsache ist, Fehler sind das, was es spannend macht.
Das stimmt man ja, aber nicht wenn es zu oft passiert. Also es gibt Sendungen, die ich z.B. total verhaue, weil ich einfach die Ammoderation schon vielleicht gemacht hab und mich dann so darüber ärgere, dass ich dann, also gut, ich möcht schon, das ist vielleicht eben, die Sache bei mir ist was anderes, ich möcht eben irgendwann mal wirklich sagen, okay, ich bin an einem Punkt, wo ich sagen kann, ich kann jetzt zum normalen Radio überwechseln, ja. Ich möcht das ja wirklich professionell, also richtig beruflich machen und deshalb leg ich auch so einen Wert darauf, dass ich saubere Sendungen hinleg. Das ist vielleicht eine andere Sache mit dem freien Radio bei anderen Leuten, also deshalb mein ich das.
Ich würde gerne mal ein bisschen in die Zukunft schauen, wir haben ja auch schon mal die Frage gestellt hier, also wie würde so dein Radioformat der Zukunft aussehen, was würdest du dir da so vorstellen, was würdest du besser machen am Radio, so insgesamt an der Form? Also wie es zum Beispiel Fritz macht, die Talksendungen finde ich schon mal super, also wie ich es besser machen würde, also wie könnten die Leute noch mehr in das Radio eingebunden werden, oder das wollen, findest du es gut, dass die Leute wirklich jeden direkt beim Radio abladen können?
Nein, auf keinen Fall jeden Tag, also ich meine, es kann auch ziemlich gefährlich sein, und dann gibt es halt ein Durcheinander, denke ich mal, also wenn jetzt bei Fritz plötzlich jemand reinrufen würde, oder ich weiß nicht, wie meinst du das, also dass sich jemand reinruft plötzlich ins Radio, oder wie? Oder wie soll das jetzt?
Nee, also ja natürlich auch, das ist jetzt so, wenn Leute anrufen, oder auch zum Beispiel so On-Demand-Geschichte, Also versuchen wir einfach mal so ein bisschen ganz quer oder ganz unstrukturiert mal so überzuerlegen, wie könnte Radio in 10 Jahren, 5 Jahren, in 20 Jahren, wie auch immer aussehen?
Also was ich glaube, wie es aussehen wird, dass es wie es jetzt schon ist, dass immer mehr immer mehr Wortknappheit herrscht, immer mehr Musik, immer mehr diese Formatradios sich weiterentwickeln werden, also was keine positive Entwicklung ist.
Ja, wobei da darf man sich nicht vertun. Formatradio heißt nicht, dass der Wortanteil knapper ist, also Formatradio.
Ja, aber es heißt ja immer, Wortknappheit herrscht. Also, desto weniger Wort, desto besser funktioniert das Radio. Also, Fritz, du hast das Gegenteil irgendwie beweisen, aber du sind ja auch öffentlich rechtlich und ich denke, dadurch habt ihr auch einen Vorteil. Ich weiß nicht, ob man sowas machen könnte.
Also, sagen wir mal, das Credo, was dahintersteckt, hinter dieser Wortknappheit, kann man ja für diejenigen, die sich immer fragen, warum ist das eigentlich, so mal kurz formulieren. Wenn jemand irgendwas sagt, dann könnte sich derjenige, der da zuhört oder diejenige, möglicherweise an dem stören, was derjenige da sagt. Also entweder ist es nicht witzig oder es ist nicht interessant oder es beleidigt denjenigen in irgendeiner Form, weil er denkt, das finde ich jetzt aber nicht richtig, was der da sagt. Das ist wohl doch ein günstiger Fall, weil dann regt sich der oder diejenige vielleicht auf und sagt, oder höre ich jetzt aber gerne mal zu, weil wir sehen, was das Arschloch jetzt sagt. Aber in der Regel soll man sich deswegen so kurz halten, damit die Leute gar nicht merken, dass du redest. Und in dem Moment, in dem sie merken, dass du redest, spielst du schon wieder Musik. Das ist das Credo, was hinter diese Kürze steckt.
Unter besten noch sämtliche Anmoderationen durch die politische und durch die Humorkontrolle durchschicken.
Ja, das ist eben dieses immer mehr kontrollieren und ja, keine Aufregung mehr sorgen. Das ist das, was ich eben nicht gut finde. Also, das sollte so, es wird ja immer mehr gemacht, leider. Von den ganz kommerziellen Sendern, ob das gut ist, ich finde es nicht gut. Also, ich würde auch gerne Radio machen, wie ein bisschen mehr Wort, ein bisschen mehr Anrufe reinnehmen, wie ihr zum Beispiel haben.
Ja, das wird auch noch kommen. Ich meine, das kannst du jetzt auf deiner Plattform vielleicht nicht machen, aber wir drücken dir auf jeden Fall die Daumen. Und Christoph, wir haben alle mal klein angefangen. Und ich rede jetzt hier bei Fritz. Ich habe damals auch Uniradio gemacht und habe Sendungen gemacht. Wenn ich mir die heute noch mal anhöre, dann haben die so einen gewissen Slapstick-Charakter. Ich kann sie jetzt versuchen. Ja, natürlich manchen. Also es waren, es sind Teile. Ich höre sie immer wieder gerne, weil es sind auch Sachen drin, wo ich sage, ey, das war ja geil. Ich meine, das ist zwischen, da kommt Grütze, geil, Grütze, aber trotzdem denkst du, das war ja nett. So. Und im Grunde machen wir alle heute Radio auch immer noch so, dass eben noch genau diese Fehler passieren sollen. Da können sie vielleicht besser auffangen.
Ihr macht es eben so, wenn ihr jetzt irgendetwas macht, ihr spielt euch ja nicht auf jetzt irgendwie und seid wie auf Ecstasy und redet wahnsinnig gedrillt daher, sondern ihr redet ja ganz normal und habt Wortpausen. Es ist nicht wie jeder andere Sender. Es ist nicht dieses Pop, wie bei Popstars oder sonstiges.
Ich kann es mal kurz vormachen, wie der Privatsender ist. Nee, warte mal, wir müssen mir jetzt einen Text überlegen, den ich ganz schnell drücken kann.
Wir haben da gleich mal was.
Wir haben da gleich was. Wir haben gleich so ein kleines Potbrill zusammengestellt. Für euch, nur für euch und nur für euch.
Genau, also die Top-Hits und die besten Hits und so weiter halt. Und das ist eben sympathisch. Und so würde ich mich freuen, wenn Radio später ausschauen würde. Wenn es nicht zu professionell ist, aber auch nicht zu unprofessionell.
Ja, die Top-Hits des 17. 18. 19. Jahrhunderts und das Beste von heute. Vielen Dank für den Anruf, Christoph. Vielen Dank auch.
Und viel Spaß beim Radio machen.
Ja, das Chaosradio auf Ritz. Kurz nach elf haben wir es. Wir haben noch knappe zwei Stunden Zeit zu quatschen. Frank und Max im Studio und der DJ im Hintergrund, DJ Cole aus Wien, der jetzt mal ein bisschen Mucke auflegen wird, weil unser Mund ist schon ganz trocken. Wir sprechen uns in drei Minuten wieder. 031 77 97 110 ist die Nummer für diejenigen, die mitreden möchten von euch. 80 Jahre Radio, das Thema. Radio der Zukunft. Was mögt ihr an Radio und was mögt ihr nicht? Was ist doof, was ist scheiße oder ist Radio vielleicht längst schon tot? Das Chaosradio hier auf Fritz, letzter Mittwoch im Monat. Und wir haben natürlich ein bisschen was vorbereitet. Thema heute 80 Jahre Radio. Die meisten von euch haben ja die Gichten in den Fingern und wissen gar nicht mehr, wie sie einem Knopf drehen sollen. Da ist der eine Sender, nämlich Fritz, schon total fest eingebacken. Wir möchten auch, dass ihr bei uns bleibt. Wir möchten auch, dass ihr mit uns talkt unter 031 77 97 110. Aber wir haben jetzt mal simuliert, was passieren würde, wenn ihr einfach an diesem Knopf dreht. Und das Geile ist, ihr müsst überhaupt nicht wegschalten.
Hertha ist jetzt 15. Zeit 18.34. Das Berlin und Brandenburg wettet die Aussichten. Vielen Dank, Ingo. Der schnellste Verkehrs- und Blitzerreport für Berlin und Brandenburg.
Informationen, Informationen, Informationen.
Da heißt es dann EG Metall-Chef Klaus Zwickl, EG Bau-Chef Klaus Wiesehügel und Verdi-Vorsitzender Frank Bzerske.
Niemand will den Bundeskanzler stürzen. Das ist sekundär.
17 Uhr, Manipulation des Bewusstseins.
18 Uhr, die Nachrichten. 19 Uhr, die Nachrichten. Bundesgesundheitsministerin Schmidt, Bundesinnenminister Schiele, Bundeskanzler Schröder, der französische Präsident Chirac, der polnische Staatschef Kwasniewski, Generalbundesanwalt Nehm, Landesumweltministerin Höhn, SPD-Generalsekretär Scholz, Wirtschaftsminister Kliment, um nur einige zu nennen, Informationen.
Die Nachrichten.
Nach den Nachrichten hier die Informationen am Abend.
Informationen am Abend.
Zunächst die Nachrichten. Zunächst die Meldungen. Zunächst die Übersicht.
Und hier geht es jetzt wieder weiter mit mehr 70ern und mehr 80ern.
Jetzt neu die Kult-Hits von gestern und heute.
Jetzt wird SuperMixXL und hier geht es jetzt wieder weiter mit mehr 70ern und mehr 80ern. Das ist alles sehr unterhaltsam und lustig.
Ja, dann wünsche ich dir auf jeden Fall viel Spaß und Ihnen gute Unterhaltung. Längste 80er-Party der Welt. Die coolste Partymusik aus den 80ern.
Morgen anfangs freundlich. Eine Besserung der Lage ist frühestens Ende des Jahres in Sicht. Soweit die Übersicht. Die Meldungen im Einzelnen. Berlin. Berlin, Berlin, Berlin.
Hier ändert sich nichts. Informationen, Informationen, Informationen.
Berlin, Berlin, Berlin, Berlin.
Hier ändert sich nichts.
Soweit die Meldungen. Die Übersicht im Einzelnen. Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland. Die nächsten Nachrichten am 10. Mai 1933.
Ein geiles Teil. Ein geiles Teil seppen ohne umzuschalten hier auf Fritz. Und ich setz noch einen drauf.
Und im Radio Fritz.
Ja genau, wir können das nämlich auch.
Das ist ein Snippet gewesen aus dem Juniradio, das hat der Sebastian Lindgaard unter anderem mitgemacht. Und ja, wir konnten uns es nicht verkneifen, das hier nochmal reinzuhauen.
Heiße Scheiße, kann man nur so sagen. Ja, Informationen, Informationen. Am Telefon ist jetzt, lasst mich kurz orientieren, die...
M, mit M war das.
Die Mandy, die Mandy.
Deswegen sagst du, ich dachte schon, was ist denn mit dir los. Mandy aus Friedrichshain, hallo Mandy.
Ich wollte ja nur mal sagen, ich hab ja schon einige Beiträge von euch gehört jetzt. Und ich finde, Radio ist glaube ich immer mehr am Kommen jetzt. Es hat so glaube ich eine Weile lang etwas nachgelassen. Also so Anfang der 90er, so bis Ende der 90er und es kommt jetzt wieder ganz stark als Medium. Und ich finde, die wenigsten Menschen haben heutzutage noch Muße, Radio zu hören. Ich glaube, gerade radioaktiv hören, dazu gehört auch schon ein Stück weit Muße. Man muss sich wirklich auch hinsetzen, sich die Zeit nehmen, Tee machen und wirklich zuhören. Ansonsten ist es ja wirklich nur ein Nebenbei-Medium.
Das ist aber auch dieser umgekehrte Effekt, dass Radio eben fürs, haben wir auch gehört, fürs Relaxen einen totalen Nutzwert hat, dass man eben entspannen kann dabei, weil man sich nicht so konzentrieren muss. Sich dafür zu konzentrieren ist allerdings umso krasser.
Ja genau, obwohl viele Themen, also gerade Blue Moon, Chaos Computer Club ist eins meiner Lieblingssendungen, weil man auch viel Informatives bekommt. Aber ich wollte eigentlich, was so das Schöne am Radio ist, das wollte ich noch mal aufgreifen für mich. Wie gesagt, diese Ruhe, die man hat und dass man sich wirklich hinsetzt und wirklich aktiv zuhört. Wobei ich sagen muss, dass das auch wirklich von den Moderatoren abhängt. Also ich finde auch ganz wichtig ist, wer die Moderation macht. Da ist Stimme wichtig und was derjenige sagt, wie derjenige moderiert. Das ist für mich wirklich ein Grund, entweder wegzuschalten oder dran zu bleiben.
Was sind da die Kriterien für dich?
Ja die Kriterien, wie gesagt, eine Stimme ist ganz wichtig für mich. Und diese, also ich bin auch so ein typischer Wechselhörer, weil ich kann einige Moderatoren jetzt nicht so unbedingt ertragen und schalte dann um und höre lieber Musik und schalte dann aber wieder zu bestimmten Sendungen, wo ein bestimmter Moderator, den ich sehr gerne mag, meine Singer Fritz, schalte ich dann auch ein, weil mir halt der Anspruch halt gefällt, auch teilweise das Wissen, das Hintergrundwissen, was jetzt bei Scripps auch sehr stark ist, dass man Themensendungen hat, wo man auch Leute hat, die wirklich dazu auch Hintergrundwissen haben und das auch weitergeben.
Wobei ich das fast mittlerweile wichtiger finde als die Stimme an sich, weil die Stimme an sich, muss man jetzt einfach mal sagen, die meisten können ja jetzt hinter die Kulissen des Radios nicht blicken, weil Fritz ist es so, da wird an der Stimme nicht besonders viel gemacht. Also es gibt solche Teile, die sitzen da vorne, also mein Mikrofon ist da dran angeschlossen, und da werden bestimmte Frequenzen hin und her geschoben und gezogen, damit man zum Beispiel die Stimme im Radio auch gut hört, weil es gibt Leute, die haben einfach eine relativ blasse Stimme, und wenn die irgendwas sagen würden, auf Musik oder so, obendrauf, dann würde man die nicht hören. Und bei Fritz ist das relativ soft, da wird das einfach nur so gemacht, dass das okay klingt, aber es gibt zum Beispiel Privatsender oder so, da kannst du eine Gurkenstimme haben bis zum Get-Know, also wirklich bis zum Himalaya, und dann drücken die so ein paar Knöpfe und dann hören sich alle an wie Privatsendern Nummer eins. Deswegen klingen die beim Privatradio nämlich auch alle gleich.
Ja, also ich finde auch den Anspruch, den der Moderator hat, oder die Art, wie er redet, ist auch für mich ausschlaggebend. Also es gibt auf einigen Sender hier in Berlin Leute, die sich auch so agen ausdrücken und in wirklich Aussprache, die einfach schlimm ist. Und da hat man einfach keine Lust, diesen Gesappel dann auch so zuzuhören. Also ich mag vor allen Dingen auch Menschen, die dann auch wirklich, man hat gesehen von der Stimme jetzt auch, wirklich sich auch gewählt ausdrücken können, was ja auch so ein bisschen verloren gegangen ist in Berlin.
Ich kann ja gewählt sabbeln.
Also gerade bei den Mainstream-Sendern, wo dann irgendwie immer Scheiße und also wirklich ganz schlimme Themen auch in eine ganz schlimme Art, eine ganz schlimme Art zu sprechen.
Echt, das sagt man Scheiße im Radio?
Und das ist mir dann auch zu viel. Was ich aber auch sehr gerne höre im Radio sind zum Beispiel Hörspiele. Weil da ist auch wieder die Art, man kann sich in so eine Fantasie wieder zurückziehen, man hat so seinen eigenen Film dazu und es ist eben auch von früher. Ich weiß nicht, kennt ihr das noch früher, dieses Soap, das es gab? Was ist denn heute da befindlich los? Kennt ihr das?
Nee, ich nicht.
Das war irgendwie auch so Spreeradio, das war eine Kindersendung mit Familie und da war man immer gespannt, was ist denn heute da passiert. Also da haben wir wirklich vom Radio gesessen und haben das mit Begeisterung gehört und ich glaube, Hörspiele, das ist nicht mehr so im Radio, kann man das nicht mehr so hören.
Sag mal, du meintest vorhin, Radio, du glaubst, dass Radio im Kommen ist. Max, ist das tatsächlich so? Hast du da aktuelle Zahlen? Ist Radio wirklich im Kommen?
Puh, also ich bin da kein Experte, was diesen ganzen Background anbelangt, ich weiß nur, dass die Zahlen, also dass alle Radios im Berliner Raum grundsätzlich an Hörern verloren haben. Das liegt aber, Berlin ist halt auch so ein echt spezielles Pflaster, weil das haben wir in der Welt, Berlin hat den härtesten Radiomarkt und die Leute sind sehr übersättigt und gerade wenn die Radios sich präsentieren, da gibt es so bestimmte Phasen, da sieht man halt überall Plakate und denkt dann so, oh Mann, jetzt habe ich aber auch die Schnüsse voll. Das kann man in Berlin schwer beurteilen, aber es ist so ein bisschen gesunken ist, ist ganz offensichtlich. Aber warum glaubst du denn, dass das im Kommen ist?
Ja, es ist irgendwie, wenn man die Leute so hört, also meine Eltern, wir hatten neulich das Gespräch mit meinen Eltern, hört ihr noch Radio? Dann haben die gesagt, wir haben früher Radio Luxemburg gehört. Ja, mal so. Das war so ihr Radio, da wurde eben auch so was erzählt, was die Leute eben halt auch angesprochen hat. Da wurde halt auch viel Unsinn gemacht anscheinend. Ich hab's nie gehört. Aber ich glaub, das ist so ein Kommen, man hört das so aus den Ecken. Wenn man so in gewisse Kreise geht, dann sagt man, mich hast du denn gestern die Sendung gehört oder gerade bei euch, also ich hör's auch oft, Fritz oder Radio 1, sag ich mal, da ist jetzt so ein bisschen, das ist so modern gerade, Radio zu hören und gerade diese Sender zu hören. Mal weg von diesem Mainstream, sondern auch mal hin zu hören. Ich kann es jetzt nur sagen, ich weiß nicht, ich hab das Gefühl, als wenn es im Kommen ist.
Ich hab ja das Gefühl, dass das Hörspiel im Kommen ist, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, weil du meintest vorhin, weil zum Beispiel Hörbücher, also das ist ja wirklich der Boom, dass die Leute sich diese Dinge als Hörbücher nochmal reinfallen, da liest einfach einer dieses Buch vor. Und es ist ja nicht so, als wären die Leute, die sich solche Teile anhören, faul wären oder so. Es gibt Studien, dass die, die sich Hörbücher kaufen, die größten Leser. Ich finde es nur so geil, mich ins Auto zu setzen. Ich weiß, ich habe jetzt eine halbe Stunde Zeit und lasse mich irgendwie Harry Potter reinpfeifen. Es ist so geil.
Ja, das finde ich auch ganz toll. Also ich wollte noch was sagen zu den Gewinnspielen. Ihr hattet vorhin am Anfang gesagt, dass diese Mainstream-Sender mit Gewinnspielen locken. Also ich hatte mal eine Freundin, die hat dann Radio gearbeitet in Berlin und es ist ja der totale Fake. Also nicht, dass alles so ist, aber es ist ja teilweise der totale Fake.
Was kennst du dafür Geschichten?
Na ich kenne einfach eine Geschichte, ich habe halt im Büro gearbeitet und dann rief die mich an und sagte, ja hallo, wie geht's? Und sie sprach und sie sagte, ich sitze gerade im Sender, kann ich dich in einer halben Stunde nochmal anrufen und dann machen wir hier so ein Gewinnspiel. Und da musste ich halt einen Synonym machen, ich bin Sabine aus Köpenick und ja Sabine, du hast jetzt gewonnen hier an Freimachttag, oder weißt du, was das war? Und da musste ich halt was spielen, damit es so aussieht, als ob ich da gewonnen habe.
Ja, aber das ist sowas, da kann man ja mal ein bisschen aus dem Nähkästchen plaudern. Da habe ich gedacht. Das ist tatsächlich so, das wird gerne gemacht, und zwar aus einem Grund, der Hörer ist im Programm der unberechenbarste Faktor, den man sich vorstellen kann. Zeitlich und inhaltlich überhaupt nicht vorhersehbar. Du kannst natürlich mit Menschen vorher sprechen, aber was der dann tatsächlich macht und ob der dir nicht noch einem vom Pferd erzählt, das kannst du nicht wissen. Bei uns ist es so, wir machen auch gerne Gewinnspiele und wir machen diese Gewinnspiele live. Also wenn du einen Privatradio-Menschen triffst und erzählst ihm, dass du deine Gewinnspiele live machst, dann packt er sich an den Kopf und sagt, sei mal, seid ihr eigentlich total irre? Weil ich kenne das ja auch, ich mache ja auch Tagesprogramm bei uns, also von 16 bis 19 Uhr und ich habe manchmal Gewinnspiele, da geht dann irgendwas, löst sich dann nicht auf und dann sitzt du da dreieinhalb Minuten und wirst diesen Preis nicht los, weil du irgendwie zwei Gurken am Rohr hast und die sagen dann immer so, ja, ist das denn, warte mal, die 25? Nee, ist es nicht, nein, natürlich nicht, es ist doch bestimmt die, was sagst du denn Mike, die 21?
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Und dann geht das halt so hin und her und sowas passiert natürlich nicht, wenn und das machen die meisten, die Sachen vorher aufzeichnen. Die zeichnen nicht vorher auf, die zeichnen die Antwort auf und sagen die, Mensch, Mandy, du hast gewonnen und dann zeichnen die noch so ein, jo, das ist ja toll und dann droppt der Moderator das einfach mit so einer Taste und alle denken, da hat jemand was gewonnen.
Ich frage mich, wo kann man das auch wirklich ernst nehmen?
Na ja, das ist Sache der Hörer, denke ich.
Also das hat mich schon ganz schön umgehauen und da dachte ich so, okay.
Hast du ernsthaft was anderes erwartet?
Nein, nicht wirklich. Ich bin ja nicht naiv, aber das war schon so ein Knaller, wo ich dachte, die haben damit wirklich geworben, über eine gewisse Zeit lang, um natürlich höhere Einschaltquoten zu bekommen und wo ich dachte, ich war dann irgendwie dreimal eine Janett, eine Sabine und eine Christine. Echt?
Und hast du denn wirklich was dafür auch gekriegt?
Sie hat dann alle möglichen Freunde angerufen, damit das Programm läuft.
Hast du denn dafür dann auch was gekriegt wenigstens?
Ja, sie hat ein Praktikum da gemacht. Also es ist natürlich schon sehr interessant da mal rein zu gucken, ja. Weil man, ich glaube man kommt auch nicht so gut ran, also nicht, man kommt nicht so ans Radio ran, wenn man da arbeiten möchte. Es ist glaube ich ein Glückstreffer, wenn man da mal ein Praktikum machen kann. Also wie gesagt, was ich auch noch ganz toll finde für die Zukunft, finde ich zum Beispiel die Sachen, dass man eure Sendung auch im Internet glaube ich auch im Nachhinein noch mal hören kann.
Also zumindestens das Chaosradio.
Ja, richtig.
Das machen auch übrigens ganz ganz viele Leute. Da sind wir auch überrascht darüber. Also ich glaube die Spitzenreiter war sowas, glaube ich, irgendwie so 20-25.000 Mal.
Also ich nutze das auch, weil wir eben auch pendeln von Thüringen und Berlin und wenn wir halt nicht da sind am Mittwoch und das nicht hören können, dann sagen wir, kein Problem halt, das können wir halt den nächsten Tag dann runterladen. Das ist, finde ich, also ein ganz großer Vorteil. Ich glaube da geht auch die Zukunft hin, dass gerade Internet und Radio eben auch immer mehr verbunden werden und interaktiv halt im Radio. Ich glaube, die Leute wollen auch, dass sie selbst Interaktion machen können im Radio halt.
Ich weiß nicht, zum Beispiel, ich überlege jetzt natürlich auch die ganze Zeit, wo du sagst, Radio ist im Kommen. Ich finde ja, was auch so ein bisschen so ein Faktor ist, das könnte jetzt ein bisschen Inspiration sein zu den nächsten anderthalb Stunden, die wir noch haben, dass diese ganze Bilderflut, auch diese ganzen schlechten Bilder, die man mittlerweile übers Fernsehen vermittelt bekommt, also Krieg, Abschlachten, Mord und Todschlag und so dieses amerikanische Fernsehformat, was immer stärker auch hier kommt, Radio lässt einem noch so ein bisschen die Möglichkeit, sich im Zweifelsfall davon zurückzuziehen. Auch wenn dir einer in Nachrichten erzählt, da hat sich jemand den Fuß mit der Kettensäge abgeschnitten. Das ist zwar dann so ein kleiner Zucker, aber wenn du das Bild nicht gesehen hast, dann musst du es dir nicht unbedingt mitnehmen. Und da ist das Radio sehr charmant und zurückhaltend in bestimmten Belangen.
Also gerade im Fernsehen sehen die Bilder, lassen die auf sich einprasseln und wollen auch nicht mehr denken. Also die sind halt so angestrengt. Das meine ich halt. Diese Muße haben die wenigsten, sich wirklich auch mit dem Thema auseinanderzusetzen in dem Fall.
Also auf die Muße.
Die Muße.
Aber nochmal eine kurze Frage. Du hast gesagt, du hörst die Sendung auch im Nachhinein an. Wäre das für dich auch eine Möglichkeit, dass du sagst, du stellst dir dein Radioprogramm selbst zusammen? Also das ist praktisch so ein personalisiertes Radio?
Na, die Möglichkeiten habe ich leider nicht.
Also wenn es die gäbe, zum Beispiel, es gibt halt eine Webseite, ein Service, wo du sagst, ich will irgendwie die Information haben, klick die Musikrichtung und klick die Werbung.
Ja, das würde ich ganz toll finden. Weil dann müsste ich mir endlich nicht diese schreckliche Musik anhören, sondern könnte wirklich, genau wie du sagtest, die ganzen Komponenten so zusammenstellen, wie sie gerne hätten. Also das wäre toll, für mich wäre das ideal. Weil dann könnte ich wirklich Radio hören, wenn ich Zeit habe, wenn ich die Muße habe und könnte dann ganz aktiv, also wirklich das hören, was ich möchte.
Mal gucken, vielleicht kommt sowas ja mit Digital Broadcasting oder so, Digital Audio Broadcasting, könnte ja möglich sein. Was wir mal gemacht haben übrigens beim Uniradio war, eine Sendung Stereo zu senden und zu splitten. Links die eine Sendung, rechts die andere Sendung. Dann konnten sich die Leute dann aussuchen, was sie hören. Ob sie Musik hören oder ob sie den Wortbeitrag hören. War natürlich mit dem Monoradio ein bisschen angeschissen, aber egal.
Ben Fritz in Panko, dann 1002, 6.
Mit dem Wetter, ach du dickes Ei. Wo habe ich das denn hingelegt?
Hätte ich doch mal eins mitbringen sollen.
Ja, Mario hat... Ich hab's, Leute. Das Wetter. Der Abend und die Nacht sind überwiegend stark bewölkt. Das wusste ich doch noch aus dem Kopf. Teilweise kann es Regen geben. In der Nacht sinken die Temperaturen auf 4 bis 1 Grad. Morgen ist es weiterhin ziemlich wolkig, besonders am Vormittag auch Regen, was alles doof ist. Die Temperaturen steigen maximal auf 10 Grad. Und jetzt die Meldung mit Mario Bartsch.
Der saarländische SPD-Chef Maas wird bei der Landtagswahl 2004 als Herausforderer von Ministerpräsident Müller CDU antreten. Das gab Maas nach einer SPD-Vorstandssitzung in Saarbrücken bekannt. Er beendete damit Spekulationen über eine Rückkehr des früheren Bundesfinanzministers Lafontaine in die politische Spitze. Der US-Investor Philipp Anschutz bekommt offenbar rund eine Million Euro vom Berliner Senat für sein Großhallenprojekt am Ostbahnhof. Da schreibt die Berliner Zeitung unter Berufung auf Stadtentwicklungsenator Strider. Bislang hatte der Senat stets betont, dass Anschutz keine Zuschüsse aus der Landeskasse für das Projekt erhalte. Ein ziviler Testjet ist in der Nähe von Brandenburg in Oberbayern abgestürzt. Der Alpha-Jet bohrte sich auf einem Feld in den Boden. Das Schicksal der beiden Besatzungsmitglieder ist noch unklar. Die Polizei vermutet aber, dass sie ums Leben gekommen sind. Die britische konservative Partei hat ihren Vorsitzenden Duncan Smith abgewählt. Das ist das Ergebnis einer Vertrauensabstimmung der konservativen Unterhausabgeordneten. Als Favorit für die Nachfolge gilt der frühere Innenminister Howard. Und zum Sport. In der zweiten Runde des DFB-Pokals ist Union Berlin ausgeschieden. Die Berliner verloren gegen Bayer Leverkusen mit 0 zu 5. Eine Runde weiter sind neben Leverkusen auch Braunschweig, der HSV Freiburg, Aachen, Duisburg, Kreuth, Ringsburg, Hoffenheim und Orosia München-Gladbach. Der Verkehr auf Fritz mit einer Meldung von der A10. Südlicher Berliner Ring Potsdam Richtung Schönefelder Kreuz. Zwischen Pferch und Potsdam Süd sind wegen Brückenarbeiten zwei Fahrstreifen gesperrt und zweimal die A111. Einmal Oranienburg Richtung Charlottenburg. Zwischen Schulzendorfer Straße und Kurt-Schumacher-Damm ist die Autobahn wegen Instandhaltungsarbeiten gesperrt. Eine Umleitung ist eingerichtet. Und nochmal A111 Charlottenburg Richtung Oranienburg diesmal. Im Tunnel Flughafen Tegel ist der rechte Fahrstreifen wegen Bauarbeiten ebenfalls gesperrt. Ansonsten gute Fahrt.
Jeden Samstag im Columbia Fritz Berlin. Fritz die Fete, das Original. Tanten auf zwei Floors und chillen im kuscheligen Winterzelt. Fritz die Fete ist nur echt mit der Super-Duper-Geburtstagsaktion. Und die geht so. Wer diesen Samstag oder Sonntag Geburtstag hat, feiert mit sechs Freunden umsonst. Fritz die Fete. Das Original. Samstag 23 Uhr, Columbia, Fritz, Berlin. Und im Radio Fritz.
Da wird sich schon geräuspert. Das kann nur das Chaosradio sein. Und das hört ihr auch. Auf Fritz, wir haben den Zenit überschritten, also nicht unseren, nicht mal alterstechnisch, sondern den der Sendung. Das heißt, wir haben noch so knapp eineinhalb Stunden Zeit zu talken. Thema heute Abend, 80 Jahre Radio, was Historisches. Und deswegen reden wir über eure Radio Vorstellungen. Seid ihr zufrieden damit, was so im Radio passiert? Da muss es jetzt nicht nur um Fritz gehen, da geht es um alles mögliche. Also sei es tolle Beiträge, geile Reportagen, super Musikstrecken, alte Moderatoren, wo man schon hinten hört, dass die schon die eine oder andere Rachenbehandlung hinter sich haben und man denkt, so viel Whisky möchte ich auch mal getrunken haben. Sowas zum Beispiel. Darüber möchten wir heute Abend reden im Chaosradio. Und am Telefon ist der Christian aus Trebin. Hallo Christian. Deine Geschichte dazu.
Ja, also als erstes würde ich ganz gerne beginnen. Ihr hattet ja auch in die Runde gefragt, wie man sich denn vorstellen möge, dass Radio dazu kommt. Und ich glaube, dass es wichtig wäre, aus meiner Sicht. Man kann da natürlich nur subjektiv urteilen, aber aus meiner Sicht wäre es ganz hilfreich, wenn Fritz in Zukunft ein Format anbieten würde, dass zum Beispiel einem Hörerclub ähnlich kommt, aber dieser Hörerclub von den Hörern vollkommen selbst gestaltet wird, sowohl redaktionell als auch dann, was den musikalischen Teil angeht.
Was heißt das genau, Hörerclub, also wie stellst du dir jetzt sowas vor, wie soll das laufen organisatorisch?
Ja, dass man das Hörer sich zusammenschließen können, bewerben können, mit einem Sendekonzept, dieses Konzept einreichen können, für ein oder zwei Stunden. Und dann entweder per Losverfahren oder die Fritz-Redaktion entscheidet, dieses Konzept, was da vorgeschlagen wurde, ist recht gut.
So ein Prinzip wie Mixtape irgendwie nur für die Musik ist? Richtig, genau.
Aber dass man das eben auch ausweitet auf vielleicht interessante Wort- oder Aktionsstrecken. Zum Beispiel denke ich, dass es unter den Fritz-Hörern bestimmt auch Hörer gibt, die ähnliche interessante Aktionen im Kopf haben, wie der Waldländer oder wie beispielsweise 100 Stunden Flimks geht. Natürlich nicht in dem großen Rahmen. Natürlich viel kleiner, was dann auch in einer 2-Stunden-Sendung unterzubringen wäre. Aber so in etwa, dass man das Hörer selbst Konzepte entwickelt.
Das ist eigentlich cool. Das ist natürlich auch eine Herausforderung und würde auch viel Verantwortung auf den Hörer übertragen. Die Frage ist, ob alle das so wollen. Also ich finde es natürlich immer cool, aber ist die Frage, ob es im Endeffekt dann wirklich trägt.
Richtig, weil ja vorhin auch schon angeklungen ist, dass viele das Medium Radio als Begleitmedium nutzen und sich doch eher unterhalten lassen, als selbst zu unterhalten. Das ist schon wahr. Und eine andere Sache, auf die ich noch eingehen wollte, ist der Unterschied zwischen öffentlich-rechtlichem Radio und kommerziellen Radio, der mir persönlich auch aufgefallen ist, ist der, dass die Privatstationen, wie vorhin schon angeklungen, überwiegend mit Geldgewinn spielen und dergleichen werben und ihre Hörer versuchen zu finden und zu ködern, während beim öffentlich-rechtlichen Radio noch Aktionen stattfinden, die sich nicht immer im Mainstream ansiedeln, die vielleicht schräg oder kreativ sind. Ich denke, das ist der Vorteil, den man mit Hilfe des öffentlich-rechtlichen Mediums dann hat.
Klar, das liegt ja auch in der Natur der Sache, weil die Privatsender müssen sich ja darüber finanzieren, wie die Werbeeinnahmen sind. Die müssen einfach Quote, Quote, Quote bringen.
Richtig. Aber wenn ich an so eine Aktion denke wie die Wochen des Glücks. Ich wurde beispielsweise heute Morgen angerufen und hatte das Glück, ausgewählt zu werden, von Tausend Hörern dann einen Wunsch erfüllt zu bekommen. Der hat zwar leider nicht geklappt, der konnte nicht umgesetzt werden.
Schade, was war das?
Es ging um die Geschichte mit dem Saaldiener im Bundestag und das hat leider nicht geklappt. Da haben die Kollegen des Deutschen Bundestages nicht mitgespielt.
Die sind doch echt verspannt da.
Ja, und die Frips-Redaktion hat sich dennoch meiner Meinung nach dann Bein ausgerissen, um diese Sache eventuell zu ermöglichen und ich denke, alleine der Wille und die Idee, die dahinter steckt, ein Team, was sich Gedanken macht, das können wir in der Woche senden, ist eigentlich schon recht interessant.
Das macht einen Riesenspaß, das muss man dazu sagen. Weil wir heute Abend auch viel drüber reden, was ist gefakt und wo tut man so und was passiert. Da draußen, die reißen sich echt den Arsch auf, um diese Nummer zu erfüllen, weil das natürlich nicht einfach so klappt. Die sind nur am Telefonieren und wenn man denen irgendwann mal quer kommt, die sind auch schon total aggressiv. Da ist immer so dieses, ihr macht den Leuten doch, hey, ihr seid doch total gut zu den Leuten. Ja, ja, gut zu den Leuten, jetzt halt mal die Schnauze, ich muss jetzt ein wichtiges Telefonat für. Die sind halt echt, die sind echt am Ackern. Dieses Soko-Glück ist echt der Hammer.
Und was auch angesprochen wurde, was mich auch positiv stimmt, ist, dass bei euch Aktionen wirklich im Live-Charakter größtenteils stattfinden. Dadurch entsteht natürlich eine gewisse Dynamik, sowohl auf Seiten der Hörer, als auch auf Seiten der Redakteure und des Moderators. Und diese Dynamik, denke ich, sollte sich das Medium Radio erhalten, denn das Radio ist das schnellste Medium der Welt neben dem Internet. Und ich denke, gerade diese Dynamik ist ungeheuer wichtig, um im Kontakt mit den Hörern zu bleiben und um ständig sozusagen erkannt zu werden von den Hörern.
Wenn ich das so höre, nehme ich mal an, dass so ein personalisiertes Radio, wie wir ja schon mal angesprochen haben, dann für dich nichts wäre. Weil es könnte ja dann eigentlich nicht live sein, wenn du dir selbst was zusammenstellst, weil sonst würde ja irgendwie Moderation und Musik und so eine Sache nicht übereinander passen.
Das kommt drauf an. Also ich denke mal, es gibt bestimmte Bereiche, wo es sich anbietet. Zum Beispiel, wenn man einen bestimmten Servicebeitrag verpasst hat, zum Beispiel wird eine neue CD vorgestellt oder es wird gerade im Soundgarten findet jetzt ein Interview statt und man hätte diese Interview ganz gerne gehört und man kann es dann später nochmal nachhören. Diese Sachen wären schon interessant, aber komplette Sendungen wären nicht mein Fall. Also, sondern spezifische Inhalte dann. Das würde ich doch als begrüßenswert halten.
Da wird ja auch schon dran gearbeitet. Das ist sowas, da wird gerade bei klassischen Medien natürlich danach geguckt und Radio ist ein sehr, sehr klassisches Medium, dass das, was da sehr neu ist, zum Beispiel sowas wie ein Interview mit irgendeinem Künstler, noch mal im Internet abrufbar zu machen, dass die Leute das auch wirklich wollen. Und man stellt dann doch immer wieder fest, dass so viele Leute doch leider nicht vernetzt sind und so viele Leute sich diesen, was weiß ich, 20 Megabyte MP3-Brocken doch nicht runterziehen wollen und so weiter. Das muss auch alles erst mal nachwachsen, auch wenn der Frank jetzt mit ganz großen Kinderaugen guckt, weil eigentlich sind doch alle vernetzt.
Ich habe kein DSL in Friedrichshain.
Ja, du im Friedrichshain, ey. Mann, wie oft muss ich das schon hören? Die haben dir doch gerade Kupferleitungen gelegt, oder nicht? Das ist ein Trauma, da reden wir ein anderes Mal drüber.
Das Einzige, was mich vielleicht noch etwas spürt, oder was vielleicht jetzt immer mehr zu kommen scheint, ist dadurch, dass ihr auch mit einer digitalen Sendesteuerung gearbeitet, im Tagesprogramm vor allen Dingen. Da wird natürlich teilweise die Dynamik aus dem Programm herausgenommen.
Inwiefern?
Ja, ihr fahrt einen kompletten Sendeplan ab. Ich denke mal, aus meinem Hobbywissen, so viel zu wissen, dass diese Sendesteuerung, also dieser Sendeplan komplett abgefahren wird. Da steht dann links, glaube ich, die Uhrzeit, rechts in der Spalte der Interpret und danach der Wortbeitrag und so weiter und so fort. Und dass dadurch ein gewisses Maß an Spontanität dann auch verloren geht.
Na gut, wenn wir da schon mal sind, ich kann dir mal ein bisschen erzählen, was hier so ist, wenn wir schon mal über Radio reden, dann muss man dir auch mal erklären, wie das funktioniert. Also es ist so, wir sind kürzlich umgezogen, es ist jetzt schon ein bisschen her und haben Fritz auch komplett digitalisiert. Das heißt, wir senden digital von so einem digitalen Pult. Ich sitze vor einem Pult und dieses Pult hat verschiedene Regler und diese Regler sind belegt mit bestimmten Sachen. Normalerweise bei so einem alten Analog-Pult, da wäre das fest. Da ist auf dem Regler, hier ist mein Mikrofon. Wenn ich das jetzt leiser mache, bin ich wieder da. Bei diesen digitalen Dingen ist natürlich alles toll, digitale Revolutionen nicht. Da kann man dann alle Regler belegen, wie man will. Also ich könnte jetzt auf so einen Knopf drücken und dann macht das... und dann ist das alles irgendwo anders. Worauf der Christian jetzt aber anspricht, ist unser Sendeplan. Da hat er tatsächlich recht. Das ist so, wir haben hier vor uns einen kleinen Monitor. Dieser Monitor ist der Monitor von unserem Rechner im Keller. Auf diesem Kellerrechner findet das alles statt. Da ist dann zum Beispiel drin die Musik, da sind drin die Jingles. Also wir hatten das vorhin ganz kurz. Ich kann hier nochmal... Das ist ein Jingle, das nennen wir so. Das drückt ihr einfach auf so einen Knopf. Das kommt so elektronisch. Und da sind diese ganzen verschiedenen Jingles drin. Und da sind so Unterlegmusiken drin, auf die man spricht. Also jetzt hier gerade im Untergrund haben wir einen Live-DJ. Das ist keine Maschine, der Mann. DJ Cole aus Wien. Aber sowas ist da alles drin. Und jetzt ist aber der Punkt. Und deswegen finde ich das wichtig, Christian, deswegen erzähle ich das alles. Der Job des Moderators ist ja nicht nur zu reden und sich wirklich einen wegzuasseln bis zum Get-No, sondern auch eben das kreativ einzusetzen. Und die große Kunst ist eben, das dynamisch zusammenzufahren, nennt man das. Weil das ist so wie Autofahren, wenn man das macht. Und das ist immer noch ein ganz schön harter Job. Also zum Beispiel zwei Lieder so zusammenzustecken, dass die sich gut anhören, dass du wirklich auf der einen des anderen Songs, der da gerade ausklingt, den ersten Takt des anderen richtig schön draufsetzt und so. Sowas muss man können.
Und jetzt endlich sind ja auch die Moderationen nicht schon fertig geschrieben, sondern kommen freihand sozusagen.
Also das passiert schon noch. Wir haben diesen Plan zwar, aber der Plan ist halt einfach nur, es kommt jetzt alles aus einer Hand. Früher war das so, da hat es halt deine CD und du hattest den Jingle aus einem elektronischen Teil, da waren so Knöpfe drauf, da kamen dann so Kassetten rein und da konntest du draufdrücken und dann kam das Teil. Aber im Endeffekt, das Sampling macht immer noch der Moderator. Das waren so kleine Kassetten waren das.
Jaja, also du meinst, dass die Dynamik trotzdem, oder ja, dass die Dynamik trotzdem erhalten bleibt, dadurch, dass der Moderator ja nicht seinen Aufgaben entledigt wird, sondern weiterhin aktiv am Ball bleibt.
Ich kann mir sogar vorstellen, dass die Dynamik noch besser geworden ist, weil einfach alles im Griff ist. Das heißt, du musst nicht irgendwie ewig suchen. Du kannst einfach, du hast alle Jingles im Computer. Und wenn du jetzt mal Bock hast, gerade genau den Jingle zu spielen, dann kannst du das theoretisch machen, weil er einfach einen Knopfdruck nur entfernt ist und nicht irgendwo draußen in irgendeinem Regal liegt.
Ja, von der Warte aus betrachtet, würde ich dazu stimmen wollen.
Also es gibt natürlich, man kann so ein System auch missbrauchen, insofern, als man demjenigen, der das System steuert, die Kreativität so einschränkt, dass man sagt, pass mal auf, du hast das und das zu tun. Das ist aber nicht die Sache des Systems, sondern es ist die Sache des Formats. Das Format kann sagen, pass mal auf, du hast das und das zu machen, dann ist das die Regel, aber dann schränken die Regeln die Moderatoren ein. Und wenn du jemanden hast, der Kreativität mit seinem System umgehen kann, dann kann der damit besser arbeiten als früher. Also das ist immer die Sache der Vorgabe. Also würde ich sagen.
Ja, leuchtet ein. Also ich denke, man kann ja eine Sache von mehreren Seiten betrachten und die Ansicht leuchtet irgendwo ein.
Ansonsten kann ich aber auch mal sagen, digital hat auch seine Kackseiten. Ich kann digital manchmal nicht ausstehen, weil digital, du kannst so ein komisches Pool total verprogrammieren. Dann sitzt du da vor wie der Ochse vom Berg und sagst immer nur, Techniker, hilf mir, es geht gar nichts, mein Mikrofonregler ist nicht da. Und das erleben wir zwischendurch auch immer mal. Und da wünschst du dir dein altes Analog-Pool zurück, wo da einfach nur so ein Holzbalken ist, den du hin und her schieben musst und dann ist dein Mikro an. Also es hat auch seine Undurchschaubarkeitsseiten.
Und dann ist mir noch ein Punkt aufgefallen, ihr arbeitet ja eigentlich auch mit diesen sogenannten Voice-Cards.
Na, das hatte ich vorhin schon mal erzählt.
Ja, und es gibt Radiostationen im Umland, in Berlin Brandenburg, die senden ihre Moderatoren mit ihren Moderatoren Stimmen mit sehr, sehr viel Hall. Mit Hall? Ja, mit Hall, als würden die aus einem Raum senden, dessen Wände sehr, sehr viel Hall abgeben. Oder verstärken ihre Stimme extrem. Also, man bekommt schon mit.
Also, Hall ist eigentlich super selten, Hall ist ziemlich cheap.
Was es sehr gibt, ist, dass die Leute wirklich einen Pegel hochpushen. Also, dass du beim Durchsetzen einfach irgendwo hängen bleibst, weil es lauter ist. Das machen ja im Musik-Sendung im Fernsehen auch zum Beispiel. Dass du einfach irgendwo hängen bleibst, weil es da irgendwie dominanter ist, lauter die Sprache.
Aber das ist immer verboten, das geht nur bis zu einem bestimmten Pegel. Ab einem bestimmten Pegel sagt die Behörde einfach auf den Maul.
Ja klar, aber du kannst ja schon trotzdem die Sprache und das Sprachband so weit komprimieren, dass es einfach kompakter, deftiger klingt irgendwie.
Okay, ich erkläre dann nochmal was. Also komprimieren. Wir reden ja heute Abend über Radio und das ist ja nur mal das, wo wir hier arbeiten. Komprimieren bedeutet, dass man eine Stimme kennt, also ich fange mal von boah anders an. Eine Stimme ist dadurch gekennzeichnet, dass sie sich anders anhört als eine andere Stimme, dass sie andere Frequenzen in bestimmten Lautstärken hat. Also wenn eine Frau was sagt, hat die andere Frequenzbänder aktiv als zum Beispiel ein Mann. Der Mann hat so tiefere Frequenzbänder. Und jetzt ist der Trick bei so einer komischen Spezialkarte, bei so einem Voice-Ding, dass man die Bänder anhebt. Also die, die nicht so aktiv sind, werden trotzdem angehoben und wenn man das total, wenn man alle gleich anhebt, klingen alle Stimmen gleich, weil dann sind alle Frequenzen gleich aktiv. Aber wenn man das bis zu einem bestimmten Level macht, klingt die Stimme einfach voller und dicker, weil die natürlich auf mehr Frequenzen unterwegs ist. Psychoakustik nennt man das. Aber das mit diesem Hall, das ist wahrscheinlich einfach Quatsch. Ich kann dir mal zeigen, wie das kommt, wenn Leute zu zweit moderieren und man macht das Mikrofon des anderen, des Partners zu weit auf, dann...
Klingt das so, als wenn wir in einem ganz schrecklich großen Raum sitzen.
Genau, bei dir ist es laut, du bist ja der Laute, aber ich werde über dein Mikro mit übertragen und kriege sozusagen einen Echo mit. Und damit klinge ich so, als würde ich aus einer Toilette moderieren. Na gut, aber das ist jetzt zu viel und zu genug geschwaffelt von meiner Seite. Wir wollen ja noch andere zu Bord kommen lassen, Christian. Ja, vielen Dank für den Anruf, aber. So, 03.317.97.91, 080 Jahre Radio, das Thema des heutigen Abends. War aber doch schon mal eine schöne Erklärung. Kann man auch mal erzählen, oder?
Ja, warum nicht? Also ich meine, es ist ja auch Chaosradio, es ist ein Technik, es ist ja auch gut. Und wir haben ja auch einen Bildungsauftrag hier.
Oh, der Rosengard. Ja, Frank und Max hier am Start und ihr könnt mitmachen und wir bitten euch auch drum. Der Sven aus Reinickendorf ist am Telefon. Hallo Sven. Moin. Also dein Beitrag zum Thema.
Ja, ich finde Radio Fritz persönlich deswegen, ja, im Gegensatz zu den anderen Sendern, relativ gut durch diese Aufteilung unter der Woche in die verschiedenen Musikgenres. Also dass halt Mittwoch Hip-Hop ist und dann heute Mittwoch dann Power da ist.
Du meinst Soundgarden und so, ne, auf 20 Uhr.
Ja, die Sachen halt und dass es halt nicht so aufgemotzt drüber kommt, ja, ihr müsst es jetzt hören, sondern halt absolut natürlich und auf ja schon so einer fast kumpelhaften Art dann rüberkommt und ja halt persönlicher ist. Tagsüber bin ich relativ wenig zu Hause, weil es ist noch Schule, aber ansonsten finde ich Radio auch so zukunftsmäßig immer noch relativ wichtig und es ist halt so, dass man es zwar, ja wie das Mädel vorher schon gesagt hatte, man kann es auf die eine Art, also so nebenherdröseln lassen, aber man kann es auch richtig sich hinsetzen mit einer Tasse Tee und Radio hören und das finde ich halt, je nachdem was man halt für ein Typ ist, lässt man es halt nebenherdröseln oder man hört sich wirklich Radio an.
Und bist du nun aktiver oder eher passiver?
Also bei Paul bin ich absolut aktiv, da lasse ich dann wirklich alles sausen und ansonsten ja immer so, je nachdem was gerade für Musik ist, was für Thema bei Fritz ist oder so, also kommt immer drauf an.
Und ich habe gelesen hier stand als Eintracht zur Wortknappheit, wolltest du auch noch was sagen? Das hat mir nämlich vorher mal aufgegriffen, also Länge von Wortbeiträgen, wie viel wird geredet, wie viel wird nicht geredet, wie viel Musik wird gespielt.
Genau, das ist, finde ich halt auch, ja, diese Wortknappheit ist, denke ich mal, auch relativ schwierig zu definieren, weil zum Beispiel Blue Moon ist jetzt nicht irgendwie, ja, ihr müsst Fritz hören, sondern halt mit einem Thema verbunden, sodass man auch eigene Meinungen sagen kann, anrufen kann. Und bei anderen Sender ist es ja hier 70er, 80er, 90er und das Beste von heute oder bla, und das halt da gemeldet wird, wir spielen jetzt irgendwelche Hits nach in zehn Stück hintereinander ohne Werbung oder so. Und das finde ich, natürlich wird da geredet, aber ist nicht unbedingt so das Interessante und das macht für mich persönlich auch nicht Radio aus. Und wenn sie dann statt diesem Geblubber, was sie ja von sich geben, dafür Musik spielen würden, ist das okay, aber wenn man jetzt so Blue Moon oder so, da als Hintergrundmusik, dann wäre es okay und ja.
Wenn du Radio machen könntest, was würdest du da für ein Radioprogramm machen?
Ja, schwierige Sache. Ist natürlich schwierig, weil man muss sehen, dass man als Radio-Fritz jetzt immer in Fünfzeichen ein relativ breites Spektrum an Hörern findet und deswegen finde ich halt auch diese abwechslungsreiche Masche von Soundgarden her, finde ich sehr gut. Zwar ist dann in dem Moment, ist dann vielleicht bei Paul nicht unbedingt der Hip-Hopper am Radio, sondern halt nur die Leute, die das mögen, aber über die Woche verteilt hat man dann doch, denke ich mal, mehr Hörer als irgendwelche Pop-Sender.
Aber es ist natürlich schwer, also das ist das, was haben wir vorhin auch schon gehabt, dass viele Leute bestimmte Sendungen geil finden, aber immer wieder feststellen, dass du den Scheiß verpasst. Also so drei Tage später so, oh, ich wollte doch eigentlich das und das hören und dass das Radio, weil Radio so ein ungreifbares Medium ist und halt akustisch stattfindet und nicht so was ist, wo du vielleicht bei einem Fernsehsender dann dabei bist und dann Videotext irgendwie guckst, ah, okay, kommt heute Abend, muss ich reingucken oder deine, also dass zum Beispiel Leute Radioprogrammen in einer Programmzeitschrift nachschlagen. Das ist ja eigentlich auch kaum noch der Fall.
Ich habe Tageszeitungen, das ist noch mal das Fernsehprogramm, aber ich denke mal auch so krasses Programm ist eigentlich auch nicht mehr so. Man hat dann vielleicht kurz vorher, 10 Minuten, wird gesagt, ja, wir haben jetzt dieses und jenes Thema. Aber so wie bei Fritz jetzt, Blue Moon, Chaosradio, an letztem Mittwoch im Monat, gibt es, meiner Ansicht nach, in keinem anderen Radiosender.
Das ist halt die Kruxradio, ist das schnellste Medium und so aktuell, dass es meistens keine Programme davon geben kann, weil man sich nach dem aktuellen Geschehen richtet, wenn man so möchte.
Aber man weiß ja nicht, so ein Plan wie ihr, das habt so, weiß ich nicht, gibt's.
Klar, so eine Sendesschiene, die hat denke ich mal jeder Sender, ne? So fast jeder Sender.
Ja, im Grunde ja.
Wobei halt so Radiesender wie zum Beispiel hier Deutschlandfunk, Deutschlandradio, die haben ja schon auch richtig ein Programm und es ist auch im Netz und du kannst auch wirklich sagen, heute Nachmittag 14 Uhr irgendwie höre ich mir jetzt irgendwie ein Special an über meinetwegen die Asian Dub Foundation oder was auch immer.
Ja, wobei ich denke Deutschlandradio ist auch eher so ein Sender, wo man dann auch Radio hören möchte und das nicht als Musiksender nutzt, oder?
Ja, das ist kein Dudelfunk mehr und kein Unterhaltungsmedium in dem Sinne. Also zwar schon Unterhaltung auch, aber jetzt nicht reines.
Ja, U-Team, vielen Dank für deinen Beitrag.
Kein Problem, gerne wieder.
Sven, Gruß nach Reinickendorf. Ja, und jetzt haben wir ein kleines Schmankerl, oder?
Genau, unser Klassiker im Radio. Also das ist ja eigentlich, eigentlich müssten wir ein fast nieder Chaosradio Sendung spielen, weil er ist so klasse. Fischmob, hör drei.
Das war's im Jahre 1993.
Ich wünsch mir Frogger von der Gruppe Atari.
Der Rosengarten liegt nicht unter dem Tisch. Ich glaub's nicht. Ja, ich glaube, ich muss mich auch ganz kurz erholen. Wir sind zu dritt in Studio hier bei Fritz, die Person, die diese wunderschöne Musik im Hintergrund zelebriert für uns ist DJ Cole aus Wien. Angeschleppt hat den Frank-Rosengard vom Chaos Computer Club, dem ihr gegenüber sitzt. Mein Name ist Max von Malotki, Thema heute Abend auf Fritz 80 Jahre Radio. Das heißt, wir kümmern uns mal um uns selber, um das Medium Radio am heutigen Abend. Und da auch ganz vorne dabei und quasi wieder Pionierarbeit leistend, ist Frank das Radioprojekt vom CCC Camp.
Ja, wir hatten auf dem Camp, ach nee, wir haben am Telefon, haben wir den Ingo, nämlich jetzt aus Köln, vom CCC aus Köln. Erzähl doch mal, was habt ihr auf dem Sommercamp vom CCC dieses Jahr gemacht, auf die Beine gestellt?
Sommercamp hier, damals in Berlin, haben wir wieder unser Veranstaltungsradio aufgezogen, mittlerweile schon zum zweiten Mal in Berlin und zum dritten Mal insgesamt. Es gibt das Camp ja nicht nur in Berlin und ein Veranstaltungsradio, das kann man sich so vorstellen, wie es klingt. Das heißt, da gibt es das Camp und auf dem Camp gibt es ein Zelt. Und in diesem Zelt steht jede Menge Technik.
Und du bist so jemand, du kannst jetzt wirklich mal aus dem Nähkästchen plaudern, weil ich muss sagen, ich war auf der Mailingliste des Chaoscamp-Radios, also war ich mit drauf und das Lustige war, dass man einfach mal sieht, was wird alles für so ein Radio so gebraucht. Da stand immer so, wir brauchen unbedingt noch zwei Drahtlose Mikro, kann jemand irgendwas, wo man drauf schnallt? Ich bräuchte noch was zum Aufzeichnen, wir müssen uns, worauf sitzen wir überhaupt? Solche Fragen kamen da die ganze Zeit. Was braucht man alles, wenn man so ein Ding realisieren möchte?
Also es fängt ganz bestimmt erstmal mit dem bürokratischen Schnatterradatz an. Das heißt, hier in Deutschland ist die Regulierungsbehörde zuständig, dafür die Frequenzen zu verteilen. Das heißt, du nimmst ein Telefonhörer in die Hand, telefonierst mit der Regulierungsbehörde in deinem Land, also in eurem Fall in Brandenburg, und lässt dich da so lange durch verbinden, bis du bei den zuständigen Mitarbeitern bist, denen erklärst du, was du brauchst, und da du irgendwas Schriftliches brauchst, schickst du denen eine E-Mail. Die sind schon fast beleidigt, wenn man denen ein Fax schickt. Und dann hat man relativ zügig eine Frequenz, relativ zügig natürlich nur, wenn es nicht gerade in Berlin Zentrum ist und wenn es auch nur um eine temporäre Frequenz geht, also vielleicht mal eine Woche oder so. Das ist relativ einfach zu beschaffen und ist auch noch im dreistelligen Euro-Bereich bezahlbar, als Club zumindestens.
Und mal ganz kurz, also man muss zur Regulierungsbehörde oder zur Landesmedienanstalt?
Da telefoniert man sich so durch. Also die Regulierungsbehörde ist letztendlich dafür verantwortlich, die Frequenzen zu vergeben und die Landesmedienanstalt erzahlt dir erstmal die Genehmigung, dass du überhaupt senden darfst, aber das klärt sich alles, wenn man sich dadurch telefoniert, relativ schnell. Also Behörden sind zwar Behörden, aber in den Bereichen arbeiten sie auch erstaunlich schnell. Ich hatte die Frequenz tatsächlich in der Zeit vom Frühstück bis zum Mittagessen.
Ach Quatsch.
Hatt ich eine Frequenz. Ernsthaft.
Und gab es denn dabei den, wollten ihr wissen, was ihr denn sendet?
Man muss kurz anreißen, worüber das Radio sein wird. Also in unserem Fall war das einfach Chaos-Communication-Camp. Wir berichten vom Campgeschehen. Wir diskutieren über Technik-Hacken, Security, Politik, tralala. Das reicht schon. Das sind noch nicht mal zwei Seiten Text, die du dir da aus der Nase popeln musst. Und damit kannst du schon eine Sendung, eine temporäre Radiofrequenz beantragen.
Geben die dir denn auch so eine Kurzvorlesung in Sachen Medienrecht? Also nach dem Motto, wer ist verantwortlich im Sinne des Presserechts? Was darf man sagen, was darf man nicht sagen? Also weil offensichtlich jeder, der so ein Vereinsding machen möchte, dahingehen kann. Sagen die dir, wo Risiken sind, was man machen darf und nicht?
Nein, die schicken dir allerhöchstens die aktuellen Gesetze, die du sonst auch so überall in der Bücherei kriegst. Aber da kommt jetzt keiner von der Radiobehörde vorbei und erzählt dir, wann du was machen darfst.
Hör mal Ingo, also Ingo, pass mal auf Ingo. Und wie habt ihr das technisch dann gemacht? Was habt ihr dann dafür für eine Antenne angeschleppt? Wie habt ihr das gedeichselt, technisch?
Technisch geht das dann so weiter, dass du natürlich keinen x-beliebigen Sender haben darfst. Du brauchst schon einen Sender der technischen Spezifikation, also der irgendwelche Prüfziegel hat.
Den musst du dir irgendwoher besorgen.
Den kannst du dir zum Beispiel bei der Telekom leihen. Es gibt aber auch Leute, die haben sowas tatsächlich im Keller stehen. Und wenn das halt die entsprechenden Prüfziegel alle hat, dann kannst du den tatsächlich auf die Wiese stellen.
Das wird dann nochmal geprüft vorher, oder?
Nein, was allerdings schlecht ist, wenn dein Sender eben nicht die Frequenz einhält, wenn er überstrahlt in Nachbarkanäle und so weiter, dann hast du plötzlich wieder die Funkpallwagen vor der Tür stehen, die dir im schlimmsten Fall den Sender stilllegen wollen. Aber wenn du da ein bisschen drauf achtest, dann klappt das schon.
Was braucht man denn für so eine Woche Radio denn noch außer dem Sendemast, aus einem großen Mischpult? Was waren so die Sachen, wo ihr am wenigsten mit gerechnet habt, dass du sie denn letztendlich doch braucht zum Beispiel?
Du brauchst auf jeden Fall das Mischpult, du brauchst die ganze Sendeanlage, du brauchst Zuspieler, du brauchst Musikquellen, du brauchst Mikrofone, ein Telefonhybrid sollte man nicht vergessen. Was man auch nicht vergessen sollte, sind Außenübertragungseinrichtungen, das heißt, du musst irgendwie mit einer Funkeinrichtung über Feldrennen und O-Töne einfangen können, also sowas. Aber im Prinzip kann man das alles mit Leinwissen so halbwegs auf die Beine stellen. Man hat da schon so ein bisschen das Gefühl, was man braucht, was man nicht braucht. Was man vielleicht vergisst, sind technische Sachen. Man braucht ein OptiMod, das heißt, man sollte dafür sorgen, dass die Aussteuerung funktioniert. Das ist knifflig, wenn Leute am Mischpult sitzen, die vorher noch nicht Radio gemacht haben, dann übersteuert man schnell mal die Sendung. Das heißt, man sollte da ein paar Einrichtungen haben, um sowas zu verhindern. Das klärt mich aber auch recht schnell, wenn man mit Leuten spricht, die sowas schon mal gemacht haben.
Inhaltlich, was habt ihr für ein Programm gemacht die vier Tage lang?
Inhaltlich sieht das so aus, dass im Prinzip die Leute übers Camp gelaufen sind, Interviewpartner eingefangen haben, die das Sendestudio bisher haben. Dann wurden Interviews gemacht. Es gab Talksendungen, die dann etwas vorbereitet waren und es gab natürlich Musik, klar.
Und Hörerinteraktion, du hast gesagt, ihr habt einen Telefonhybriden angeschleppt. Hat das wirklich geklappt oder war das dann doch eher nur so, wir senden und die anderen hören zu, weil sie total kaputt in ihren Zelten liegen nach dem Tag?
Also das muss man vielleicht mal ganz kurz noch erklären. Das ist halt eine große Acker, wo irgendwie ein paar Netzwerkkabel verlegt worden sind und Strom. Die Leute kamen mit ihren Zelten und ihren Computern. Also die Reichweite war jetzt auch nicht so groß, dass ganz Berlin damit abgestrahlt wurde, sondern das reichte, wenn ich jetzt so richtig in Erinnerung gehabt habe, genau über das Camp rüber. Und das heißt, da sitzen Leute irgendwie auf dem Acker im Camp. Und das war ja erstmal schon mal eine Besonderheit, dass da überhaupt Telefone waren. Und jetzt hatten wir aber die Besonderheit, dass wir eine riesengroße Schnurrlostelefonanlage mit ungefähr 250 Teilnehmern da hatten. Das heißt, jeder konnte von zu Hause sein digitales Schnurrlostelefon mitbringen und sich da einbuchen in die Anlage. Und das war überhaupt erstmal so eine Telefoninfrastruktur, die erstmal geschaffen werden musste. Und es haben denn da drüber tatsächlich auch noch Leute beim Radio angerufen, oder?
Stimmt, wir hatten es ja mit dem Chaos Computer Club zu tun.
Selbstverständlich gab es dann noch unseren Internet-Stream, das heißt, es haben auch Leute von ganz draußen angerufen. Und dann hatten wir plötzlich so Phänomene, dass wir Leute aus den USA oder Kanada, einmal sogar aus Mexiko am Telefon hatten.
Das ist geil, oder?
Das ist sehr reizvoll, wenn da plötzlich deine Telefonlampe blinkt und du ein Überwiegespräch an der Struppe hast.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen. Das ist auch dieses Prickeln, das hat man auch, wenn man jetzt in Blue Moon, also zum Beispiel ruft einer an aus München oder irgendwer, der Stream über See hört und denkt sich, das ist der absolute Hammer. Die Vorstellung, dass jemand in, was weiß ich, Los Angeles, uns gerade zuhört, das ist so was, da krieg ich einen Steifen vor Aufruhr. Das ist unglaublich.
Es ist erstaunlich, wie viele Leute dann das plötzlich hören. Ich glaube, der größte Fehler, den man machen kann, ist, es gibt viele Internetradios, das sind im Prinzip nichts weiter als MP3-Playlisten. Das heißt, da doodelt ein Computer eine Musik nach der nächsten ab und noch eine und noch eine, macht ja noch so schöne Musik sein, aber das ist das, was jeder Rechner, den ich zu Hause in der Küche stehen habe, auch kann. Dazu brauche ich im Prinzip kein Medium, was sich Radio nennt. Sobald da etwas Content ist, hören die Leute zu.
Aber du kannst jetzt ein bisschen beurteilen, was das für ein Aufwand ist, also was man da für einen personellen Einsatz für braucht, um so ein Radio zu machen. Also wir haben vorhin gehört, es gibt irgendwie freie Radios, das sind halt Radios, wo die Leute irgendwie hingehen und Radio machen. Glaubst du, dass das ein tragbares Konzept ist, also dass sich wirklich so ein freier Radiosender, wo Leute irgendwie nicht Geld verdienen, wo irgendwie Leute das wirklich in ihrer Freizeit machen können und da irgendwie auch sehr viel Zeit für opfern, dass das wirklich ein tragbares Konzept ist? Oder glaubst du, dass es genau daran scheitern könnte?
Also auf dem Camp war die Situation ein bisschen speziell. Da waren Leute, die haben nichts anderes als dieses Projekt gemacht. So und von diesen Leuten, die nur Radio machen, brauchst du vielleicht zehn Leute. So und dann brauchst du noch ein paar Leute, die gelegentlich vorbeikommen und irgendwelche Sendungen fahren. Und dann hast du plötzlich dein 24-Stunden-Programm mit Content und Interviews und allem Drum und Dran. In der realen Welt ist es natürlich schwieriger. Dann hast du Leute, die normalerweise auch noch ein reales Leben haben, die arbeiten wollen und so weiter, nicht so viel Zeit haben. Ich denke, da brauchst du schon mehr Leute, vor allen Dingen, wenn du Content machen willst. Aber dass es funktioniert, das zeigen viele Radioprojekte. Es gibt Radioprojekte, die frei sind und zwar nicht zu wenig.
Abschließend, wenn ihr sowas nochmal macht, was würdet ihr besser oder anders machen wollen?
Das ist eine ganz, ganz schwierige Frage. Vor allen Dingen, weil sich so, da wieder die spezielle Situation des Cams, das Radio war fast unplanbar. Du hattest keine Ahnung, wer da war. Du hattest einen Interviewgast, zwei Minuten bevor das Mikrofon aufgeht, das erste Mal gesehen und musst dann da dir ein Interview aus der Nase pupeln. Es ist schwierig zu planen. Vielleicht würde man da ansetzen, ein bisschen mehr versuchen, das Programm zu planen. Eine halbe Stunde vorher zu wissen, was gesendet wird, das wäre schon recht praktisch. Aber im Prinzip von der Technik her, die wir da hatten, ich denke, da waren wir schon relativ professionell und da waren keine Wünsche mehr offen.
Sendesicherheit gewährleisten im inhaltlichen Sinne, das wäre es dann noch. Das ist ja immerhin etwas. Aber ich finde ja immer, das macht ja auch den Reiz aus, wenn man jemanden da sitzen hat und sich überdenkt, ich muss mir jetzt gerade erst mal eine Frage ausdenken und spiele Musik, sowas finde ich toll. Das wäre mal was ganz anderes.
Und vor allen Dingen, wenn Leute zum ersten Mal Radio machen und dann Mikrofon vor der Nase haben, so jetzt mach mal Programm. Es holbert zwar ein bisschen am Anfang, aber es macht Höllen Spaß, es macht Höllen Spaß. Es ist vor allem gemeint, grützegeil, grützegeil, grützegeil. Und im Prinzip genau das ist es.
Grützegeil. Ingo, vielen Dank fürs Interview. Und wir hoffen mal, der nächste Camp wird wahrscheinlich wieder stattfinden.
Es wird bestimmt ein Camp stattfinden.
Es wird in Holland sein, und zwar in 2005, wenn ich mich richtig informiert bin, irgendwo in Holland. Und es wird bestimmt ein Radio geben.
Wir schauen mal, hören wir uns zu. Gut, Ingo, mach's gut.
Viel Spaß in der Sendung.
Tschau.
0371 77 97 110. Wir haben noch knapp 45 Minuten Zeit zu reden über Radio. 80 Jahre Radio, das Thema am heutigen Abend im Chaosradio auf Fritz. Vom Chaos Computer Club Frank Rosengardt und meine Person Max Formalotky, der Mann im Hintergrund der Musik aufliegt. Das war ziemlich geil. Der hat echt so ein bietiges Zeug dabei. Ist DJ Cole aus Wien. Muss ich nachher, glaube ich, mal auf die Schulter klopfen. Also wirklich derbe, derbe, derbe cool. Muss mich kurz orientieren. Der Marcel, den hatte ich vorhin auch schon versprochen, dass er jetzt da kommt. Marcel, bist du noch da? Aus zwei Brücken. Du rufst an zur Zukunft des Radios, da sind wir beide ja sehr interessiert.
Ja, okay, wenn wir schon mal von zwei Brücken reden. Also ihr müsst euch vorstellen, das ist, sagen wir mal, 697 Kilometer von Potsdam. Und das ist eigentlich ziemlich ländliche Gegend. Das heißt, in einem Ort, wo ich lebe, das heißt Althornbach, das ist so ein Dorf mit 800 Einwohnern und doppelt so vielen Kühen. Da kriegt man genau einen Radiosender.
Wie hörst du uns jetzt eigentlich?
MP3-Stream, was Internet. Genau, deswegen reden wir auch über die Zukunft. Und zwar, das ist irgendwie so ein Sender, der heißt da Lü und der sendet auch Sabrücken. Und das ist unheimlich Mainstream und irgendwie so drauf ausgelegt, wir wollen halt so die Hip-Hop-Kitties hier in der Region glücklich machen. Und wenn man halt so ein bisschen andersartig ist, ist man da sehr schnell sehr unzufrieden damit. So und jetzt hab ich halt auch...
Ist das ein öffentlich-rechtlicher oder privater?
Der ist privat. Öffentlich-lehrrechtliche kriege ich hier leider gar nicht. Ja und hat man halt doch irgendwie... Also grad jetzt, wenn das durch den Fortschritt vom Internet wird, ist das dann halt doch besser, weil ich kriege zum Beispiel jetzt euch rein, Radio Fritz. Und ich hab halt auch die Hoffnung, dass halt gerade so was wie das Chaosradio, also etwas, was halt eine kleinere Gruppe von Leuten anspricht, halt das dann aber richtig sich immer mehr durchsetzen wird.
Also glaubst du, dass so ein Spatenradio im Prinzip mehr die Zukunft ist?
Ja, zumindest mal für den Teufel der Bevölkerung. Die meisten werden immer noch so faul sein, dass sie immer Mainstream hören. Hauptsache, ich muss mich drum kümmern und es kommt halt irgendwas.
Gut, aber Mainstream kann ja auch Sparte sein. Also wenn ich jetzt sage, es wäre einfach nur Dudelmusik, die Chartbreaker-Rotation, 20 Lieder am Tag mehr nicht. Und ich will die halt immer und immer wieder hören. Das kann ja auch nur eine Sparte sein.
Das ist dann halt die größte Sparte. Naja und ich meine, es heißt ja immer, wenn man sich mit irgendwelchen Leuten unterhält, ja früher war alles besser, also ich kann das jetzt nicht bestätigen. Also ich meine, ich habe ja immer noch die Hoffnung, dass es halt auch mal so wird, dass man halt immer mehr als Hörer auch selber teilnehmen kann. Jetzt zum Beispiel jetzt wie bei euch, dass man anruft, oder dass man eventuell sogar selber zum Sender wird, jetzt indem man selber einen kleinen Streamingsender aufsetzt.
Ja, ist nur die Frage der Überschaubarkeit. Also nehmen wir mal das, was momentan so im Internet schon an Angeboten da ist, wo man sich Sachen ziehen kann. Wenn man sich Portale anguckt, wo beispielsweise MP3-Musik man sich holen kann, so große Dinge, so was wie mp3.com oder so. Das ist ein Moloch. Ja, wenn du da hinkommst, du hast irgendwie was weiß ich wie viele tausend Titel und du hörst dir irgendwie zehn anderen, bis er entnervt, weil du feststellst, dass das alles scheiße war, was du jetzt erwischt hast. Da sind natürlich ein paar Perlen drin, aber es ist immer die Überschaubarkeit. Und klar, jeder ist ein Sender und wir sind ja auch Fans von dem Webblog-Prinzip, zum Beispiel, was momentan im Internet richtig hochboomt, dass jeder im Grunde so eine Art, naja, eine Mischung aus Tagebuch und Reflektion der Geschehnisse in Politik und des Tages und so weiter schreibt und so. Aber du musst die Sachen natürlich auch erfassen können. Und ich glaube, irgendwann wird es ganz wichtig sein, dass du so Aggregatoren hast, also dieses Prinzip personalisieren, das ist bei dir vorhin schonmal gefallen, Frank. Personalisieren von Inhalten, dass das irgendwann auf allen Ebenen stattfindet, sowohl im Print, also Internetprint meinetwegen auch, als auch im Radio. Dass dann man sagt, wenn irgendjemand irgendwas sagt über das Thema Urheberrecht oder so, dann möchte ich das gerne in meinem Köfferchen haben. Und wenn das im Radio, im Internetstream passiert, wird das mitgeschnitten oder so. So was wäre halt geil.
Ja, ich meine, ich bin ja auch jemand, wo sich halt die Chaosradio-Sendungen eher mal als MP3 runter lädt und dann bei der Arbeit hört, weil es halt doch irgendwo kreativ macht. Ich meine, das ist relativ selten, dass ich das jetzt live höre. Aber ich meine, wenn du jetzt sagst, Weblog oder sowas, ich meine, man hat jetzt gerade festgestellt, dass irgendwie 85% der Weblogs fernlos ist und dass da irgendwie auch niemand mitlässt. Und dass so, ich glaube, irgendwie so 60% der Weblogs sind von irgendwelchen frustrierten weiblichen Teenagern geschrieben, die sich über Pickel und Ex-Freunde ausheulen. Naja, aber ich meine, irgendwann wird es dann doch langweilig.
Ja klar, das ist dieses Ding, was ist langweilig, was ist nicht langweilig. Aber das ist im Grunde demokratisch freier Content, der einfach so entsteht und der keinerlei Reglemente unterlegt. Das ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Ich meine, wenn man selber was macht, dann muss man es natürlich auch bewerben, damit man halt auch irgendwie... Ich meine, es hat ja auch irgendwie irgendwas mit Open Source wieder zu tun, wenn man selber was macht, sag ich jetzt mal so, aus der Hacker-Sicht heraus. Und ich meine, damals auf den Niedungstag meinte auch jemand so, auch wenn es jetzt kostenlos ist oder so, braucht ihr nicht meinen, dass ihr für eure Projekte keine Werbung machen braucht.
Aber ich denke, es ist noch, also das Radio selbst ist eigentlich klassische Radio, da haben wir das Problem, dass der Frequenzbereich begrenzt ist einfach. Das heißt, es gibt nur eine bestimmte Anzahl von Sendern, die senden können. Und im Internet ist das ja beliebig. Also da ist schon mal irgendwie ein systematischer Unterschied dazwischen. Deswegen denke ich, dass man das auch so vielleicht gar nicht trennen kann. Im Internet müssen einfach andere Wege sein oder müssen andere Konzepte her, um da sowas zu machen. Wie zum Beispiel diese Personalisierung, dass man sich Sachen zusammensucht und sowas. Also das ist das einfache. Ich mache jetzt einen Radiostream ins Internet, direkt eins zu eins. Und ich denke, das ist nicht vergleichbar mit dem Radio, was zum Beispiel irgendwie im Autoradio läuft oder was ich irgendwie im Borgmann in der U-Bahn höre. An der U-Bahn vielleicht nicht, aber woanders hören kann. Da sind einfach noch mal Unterschiede von dem, von den Leuten, die ich erreichen will, oder von dem auch, was die Leute davon erwarten.
Ich schätze mal schon, dass man fünf Jahren oder zehn Jahren so weit sind, dass man halt auch Internet breitbandig mobil verfügbar hat. Also es wäre schon schön, wenn wir irgendwie ein Autoradio hätten, was weiß ich, IPv6, und da kommt dann mit UMTS, kommt dann so mein Ratesender per MP3 reingestehmt. Das fände ich schon irgendwie schick.
Das wäre geil. Also ich meine, das ist natürlich das, was Radio momentan noch so attraktiv macht. Das ist einfach da. Egal, wo du hinkommst, ist es da. Also sowas wie Wavelan, das könnte sich ja zum Beispiel durchsetzen, wenn man zum Beispiel nach Düsseldorf oder so guckt. Düsseldorf hat jetzt irgendwie mit der Stadt zusammen was gemacht, in Nordrhein-Westfalen, dass Wavelan von der Stadt verfügbar gemacht wird. Da kannst du dir, glaube ich, mit einem örtlichen Netzbetreiber oder so, kannst du dir so ein Login holen. Aber die sorgen halt dafür, dass es in der ganzen Stadt da ist, was ich ein sehr geiles Pilotprojekt finde. Und da kannst du natürlich auch sagen, hey, dann habe ich mein Wavelan-Paketchen und dann sage ich, okay, ich möchte gerne jetzt hier meinen Mac anschmeißen und höre mir die Radiosendung von Chaosradio da an, einfach über MPEG Stream. Und das ist sowas, wäre natürlich schön, wenn das auch im Auto passieren würde. Aber das wird wahrscheinlich wirklich, wie du sagst, noch zehn Jahre oder so dauern.
Ich meine, sowas hatten wir ja auf dem Camp. Also ich bin da wirklich mit dem Notebook rumgerannt, habe da irgendwo Wavelan gehabt und habe ein Radio angemacht. Ich meine, so als Pilotprojekt war das schon mal sehr interessant.
Aber ich meine, wenn die Möglichkeiten da sind, also durch das Netz, dass du wirklich auch eigenen Content zusammenstellen kannst, wie auch immer, wäre das deine Sache, die du eher machen würdest? Oder würdest du lieber so einen fertigen, kompletten Radiosender, einen klassischen Radiosender übers Netz hören?
Ich würde dann halt lieber so meinen Themenbereich, also was jetzt Radio-Geek zum Beispiel, was dann wie bei euch so aus Chaosradio und der entsprechenden Musik halt besteht, nur das halt rund um die Uhr.
Das ist halt sehr spartig, ne? Freak-Radios, da muss man auch genau die Freaks zuhören. Da hat zum Beispiel Amerika den großen Vorteil, in so einem großes Land zu sein und dementsprechend mehr Leute anzusprechen, die das mitnehmen. Also so eine Fernsehserie wie 24 zum Beispiel ist in Amerika total abgegangen, einfach weil es da genug Freaks gibt, die sich so ein komplexes Konzept von vornherein angucken wollen, weil da ein Fernsehsender so ein großes Netzwerk hat. In Deutschland hat es Glück gehabt, dass es relativ erfolgreich war, aber es hat es nicht so einfach gehabt zum Beispiel.
Ja gut, wenn wir von Deutschland und Amerika reden, haben wir ein ganz anderes Problem, jetzt auch gerade für das Internet-Radio geht. Also gerade bei uns, wir haben zwar Internet auch noch breitflächig, aber das Problem ist ja einfach Bandbreitenkosten. Vielleicht mal etwas konkreter. Wir sind ja Betreiber von einem relativ großen Portal im Internet. Ich muss ja jetzt keine Werbung machen, aber wir hauen im Monat einen Terabyte Traffic raus. Und wenn ich euch jetzt erzähle, was das kostet, okay, ihr seid wahrscheinlich Firmen, aber...
Wir würden das gerne hören, was das kostet.
Ja, einen Terabyte Traffic mit einer qualitativ hochwertigen Anbindung, das musste man zwischen 5.000 und 6.000 Euro im Monat rechnen. Und wenn ich einen Radio streamen würde, ich glaube, wir hauen damit 2x155 MBit raus, da käme ich auch weit mehr als einen Terabyte.
Was hat denn das Chaosradio für Kosten für seine zur Verfügung stellen von allen Sendungen, die es hier gibt?
Also es gab mal Gespräche, die die TCP-A-Sendung hier bei Fritz auf dem Server zu hosten. Als wir mal gesagt haben, wie viele Leute dazu greifen, wir so, nee, das doch nicht, das übersteigt unsere Möglichkeiten hier.
Ach wirklich?
Jetzt hosten wir den Kram selber. Nee, wir haben es zum Glück verteilt, es ist auch in einigen peer-to-peer-Netzwerken drinne und sowas, so dass es einfach irgendwie, weil sonst ist das gar nicht zu händeln alles.
Ja, sowas kann man eigentlich nur sinnvoll machen, wenn man an der Uni sitzt, also wo Treffik wirklich noch geschenkt ist.
Naja, die Uni zahlt ja auch dafür.
Naja, ich kenne da jetzt hier so gewisse Gegenbeispiele, die holen sich halt auf der einen Seite ein Gehwin, da kostet irgendwie Einkommen der Treffik nichts und dann schieben sie auf der anderen Seite über Schattel wieder raus, da kostet ein Ausgehen der Treffik nichts.
Aber nochmal um diese Sparkengeschichten. Also ich persönlich bin ja eigentlich gar nicht so ein Freund davon, wirklich nur so spezialisierte Sachen zu haben. Also ich finde es zum Beispiel auch immer toll, eine Zeitung in der Hand zu haben, wo dann auch mal Sachen drin sind, die ich jetzt so von mir aus nicht ausgewählt hätte, sondern dass ich einfach so diese ganze Palette vorgesetzt kriege und einfach mal eine Übersicht kriege und dann einfach auch mal in Kauf nehme und auch, also dass ich es gerne in Kauf nehme, auch mal Sachen vorgesetzt zu kriegen, wo ich mich sonst jetzt freiwillig nicht für entschieden hätte. Und genauso geht mir das mit dem Radio auch. Also ich glaube, ich will nicht immer ständig irgendwie nur mein personalisiertes Radio haben, sondern ich hätte dann zumindest auch gerne so einen Überraschungsknopf oder sowas. Das will ich jetzt auch mal hören.
Naja, es ist jetzt wie wenn du ein CD kaufst. Also ich finde jetzt ein Lied gut und ich nehme jetzt einen Kauf, dass mir die anderen gefallen oder nicht, aber ich möchte was Neues. Oder ich gehe jetzt halt gezielt ins Internet und möchte jetzt genau das Lied haben und alles andere interessiert mich nicht.
Also was ich auch spannend finde, wäre zum Beispiel sowas zu kombinieren, ob was es so bei Einkäufen wie bei Amazon oder so gibt, dass du Radio hörst und auf einmal sagt dann irgendjemand, hallo, möchten sie jetzt einen Beitrag A über Hunde in Zwingern, B über nackte Frauen, C über Whirlpools oder 4 über Frank Rosengardt hören oder möchten sie 5.2. Musik hören? Das wäre natürlich ganz interessant. Und dann hörst du das irgendwie über Swimming Pools an oder über Whirlpools und dann sagt er danach, diejenigen, die sich den Beitrag über Whirlpools angehört haben, fanden auch den Beitrag über nackte Frauen spannend oder so.
Willst du sowas ernsthaft haben?
Na ja, das mit den Whirlpools ist jetzt vielleicht nicht ganz so mein Ding.
Aber du willst dich aber auch aktiv entscheiden müssen.
Na ja, wenn du das über Voice kannst, also wenn du jetzt nicht irgendwas drücken musst oder so, dann wäre das okay. Die Frage wird jetzt irgendwann nervig. Also ist es zu nervig, diese Entscheidung treffen zu müssen. Aber zum Beispiel nehmen wir mal an, du hörst Nachrichten. Du hörst Nachrichten auf einem coolen Sender mit Nachrichten und die bieten dir an zu dem Thema, das da gerade läuft. Wenn sie dazu jetzt mehr Informationen wünschen, dann drücken sie bitte diesen und diesen Knopf und dann machen die halt ein Feature von 15 Minuten zu dem Thema, weil du es jetzt gerade spannend findest.
Also wie Webklicken im Prinzip.
Im Grunde wie Links im Radio.
Was hältst du davon?
Ja, ich meine, da brauchst du halt wieder einen Rückkanal. In unserem Fall Internet. Also ich meine, lustig wäre es schon. Man müsste es halt mal ausprobieren. Aber das gab es auch mal im Fernsehen vor vielen, vielen Jahren auf ARD und ZDF. Die haben da zwei Filme gesendet und bekonnen es halt immer zwischendrin umschalten.
Ja, interaktives Fernsehen. Also das war auch so ein Grundgedanke, den wir hatten. Also interaktives Fernsehen, mit der Art irgendwie A-la-la-la, M-H-P-E-N-D-R-I-N-G. So und was ist eigentlich die Disponenz im Radio dazu? Also wie würde interaktives Radio aussehen, wenn man das jetzt mit interaktivem Fernsehen vergleicht?
Also ich meine, ich kenne das jetzt halt von unserem Radiesender. Das fängt schon an, dass es da eine Homepage gibt, so communitymäßig, also Forum und dann halt irgendwie ein Chat, wo man halt auch irgendwie während der Sendung halt auch teilnehmen kann. Wobei, ich muss sagen, das könnte man natürlich immer noch wesentlich weiter ausbreiten. Also ich meine, ich sitze jetzt im Chat und sag jetzt, ich weiß jetzt ein Interview z.B. mit jemand, der berühmt ist und dass ich da halt selber teilnehmen kann. Und warum redet ihr denn nicht mal über sowas und sowas? Aber ich meine, das gibt es ja alles schon.
Ja, vor allen Dingen muss man eins sagen, da können wir auch nochmal, obwohl wir haben nicht mehr so viel Zeit, aber eine halbe Stunde haben wir noch, dass die Möglichkeit zur Wahl den Leuten oft vorgegaukelt wird. Und dass sie glauben, sie würden die Wahl treffen, aber sie treffen sie gar nicht. Du kannst einem ja zwei Möglichkeiten lassen, und die sind aber beide kacke für den, aber er denkt, er hat die Wahl.
Naja, ich meine, ich kann ja nicht nachvollziehen, gerade wenn es irgendwie ist, da entscheiden noch 5000 andere mit, wie es die 5000 anderen entschieden haben, und ob es da wirklich eine demokratische Wahl war. Vielleicht ist es ja jetzt wie in den Gewinnspielen, wie das Mandy vorhin angesprochen hat. Da wird den Leuten jetzt vorgegaukelt, dass da irgendwie jemand angerufen und gewonnen hat. Ich meine, ich kenne das jetzt auch von unserer Seite, so mit Gewinnspiel, mit Partnerportalen. Da ruft immer jemand an und meint, wir hatten keine Mitspieler, wir brauchen noch einen Gewinner, wer von euch braucht nur einen Skiurlaub?
Ja, das geht eigentlich nicht. Das ist ziemlich blöd. Worum es geht, ist Emotionen generieren im Radio. Es soll sich jemand freuen, und es soll sich jemand aus seiner tiefsten Seele heraus freuen. Das ist das Schlimme. Und die meisten Leute wollen sich nicht freuen. Und ich will mich auch nicht unbedingt freuen. Ich freue mich manchmal, aber ich will mich nicht irgendwie freuen, nur weil da irgendwer... Ja, super. Das ist auch ein ganz schmaler Grat. Emotionen generieren im Radio. Und damit arbeitet das Fernsehen momentan auch. Wenn ich also ganz kurz... Wir reden ja über Radio heute Abend. Aber eine Hasssendung diese Woche. Mario Bacch ist auch schon da, wartet mit den Nachrichten. Ich habe mir tatsächlich mal angeguckt, dieses Popstars. Da haben die am Montag diese beiden Bands gegenübergestellt. Und haben ihnen gesagt, pass mal auf, einer von euch fliegt jetzt jeweils aus der Band noch mal raus. Nachdem die vier Wochen lang gecastet, vier Wochen lang auf Tour haben gehen lassen, also den acht Wochen lang das Leben komplett versaut haben, stellen die die hin und setzen die dem emotionalen Druck aus, ihnen zu erzählen, einer von euch ist bestimmt scheiße, einer fliegt wieder raus. Am Ende ist keiner rausgeflogen, aber die haben die alle, komplett, jeden zum Heulen gekriegt, dass denen der Rotz aus der Nase geflossen ist. Und genau das wollen die meisten Fernseh- und Radiosender Emotionen erzeugen. Bitte den Krebskranken mit 1000 Mark am Krankenbett zum Lachen bringen. Das sind Emotionen. Und so polemisch muss man es leider hinstellen. Es ist ganz, ganz eklig geworden zum Teil. Ganz eklig. Und das, was Mandy erzählt hat, ist dagegen echt noch die harmlose Nummer.
Naja, auch ein Problem ist ja, dass wir quasi Antikommunikation treiben. Also wir haben da irgendwie einen großen Sender jetzt das Radio oder sowas und dann viele Empfänger. Aber mir kommt es irgendwie so vor, gerade weil es auf dem Land groß geworden ist, kennt man das noch so. Jeder kennt jeden und jeder kennt den Nachbarn. Also wenn man jetzt in unserer Stadt lebt, ist das schon wieder ganz anders. Und was ich halt auch sehr schön fände, wäre jetzt, wenn jetzt auch irgendwie die Hörer vom Radio untereinander sich halt irgendwie in Kontakt treten könnten.
Ahja, das können wir gerne machen. Du kannst ja kurz mal mit Christian reden. Hallo Christian. Ihr könnt jetzt reden.
Ja, also ich habe angerufen und mir ist aufgefallen, dass zeitweise doch auch wirklich das Formatradio gespielt wird. Heißt, dass ich also feststelle, dass was morgens läuft, läuft abends. Oder wenn ich das Lokalradio anmache, ist es genauso, wenn ich den NDR2 einmache. Das ist teilweise wirklich...
Manuel Christian, die müsstest du ja schon unterhalten, nicht?
Ja, wenn ich mehrmals am Tag dasselbe Lied höre, frage ich mich auch, wie muss ich das denn schon wieder spielen?
Ja, das ist richtig. Marcel meine ich, nicht Manuel. Ich merke schon, da merkst du mal, wie schwer das ist. Zwei Leute, die sich über Telefon unterhalten und der eine hat keine leitende Funktion und der andere auch nicht. Da wird es nämlich schon wieder schwierig. Christian, bleib mal dran, wir reden gleich noch. Wir müssen mal eben Nachrichten machen. Ich glaube, Mario Batsch muss grundsätzlich auch mal aufs Klo, der macht sich sonst gleich in die Hose. Marcel, vielen Dank für den Anruf.
Fritz Info.
Mit dem Wetter in der Nacht sinken die Temperaturen auf 4 bis 1 Grad. Zeitweise regnet es, am Tag ist es wolkig, besonders am Vormittag regnet es. Die Temperaturen steigen auf maximal 10 Grad. Und jetzt die Meldung mit Mario Bartsch.
Die US-Regierung hat Verständnis für den Abzug von Mitarbeitern des Internationalen Roten Kreuzes aus Bagdad gezeigt. Die Gefahr in der Hauptstadt sei höher als an anderen Einsatzorten, sagt US-Außenamtssprecher Butcher in Washington. Die humanitäre Organisation müsse ihre Angestellten schützen und folglich ihr Personal verkleinern. Der saarländische SPD-Chef Maas wird bei der Landtagswahl 2004 als Herausforderer von Ministerpräsident Müller als CDU antreten. Das gab Maas nach einer SPD-Vorstandssitzung in Saarbrücken bekannt. Er beendete damit Spekulationen über einen Rücktritt des früheren Bundesfinanzministers Lafontaine in die politische Spitze. Nach dem Absturz eines Düsenflugzeugs in Operbayern ist das Schicksal der beiden Insassen weiter unklar. Polizeihubschrauber suchten die Umgebung erfolglos mit Wärmekameras ab. Der für die zivile Nutzung umgerüstete Alphajet stürzte gestern Nachmittag südlich von Rosenheim in ein Feld. Die Werkungsarbeiten sollen heute Vormittag beginnen. Die Waldbrände in Südkalifornien haben erstmals einen Feuerwehrmann das Leben gekostet. Zwei seiner Kollegen wurden beim Kampf gegen die Flammen im Bezirk San Diego schwer verletzt. Damit stieg die Zahl der Todesopfer auf 17 an. Und zum Sport. In der zweiten Runde des DFB-Pokals ist Union Berlin ausgeschieden. Die Berliner verloren gegen Bayer Leverkusen mit 0 zu 5. Eine Runde weiter sind neben Leverkusen auch Braunschweig, der HSV, Freiburg, Aachen, Duisburg, Greut, Regensburg, Hoffenheim und Borussia Mönchengladbach. Der Verkehr auf Fritz A10, südlicher Berliner Ring, Potsdam Richtung Schönefelder Kreuz zwischen Ferch und Potsdam Süd, sind wegen Brückenarbeiten zwei Frahstreifen gesperrt. A111 Oranienburg Richtung Charlottenburg, zwischen Schulzendorfer Straße und Kutschumacher Damm ist die Autobahn wegen Instandhaltungsarbeiten gesperrt. Eine Umleitung ist dort eingerichtet. Und noch mal A111 Charlottenburg Richtung Oranienburg. Im Tunnel Flughafen Tegel ist der rechte Fahrstreifen wegen Bauarbeiten gesperrt.
Es ist immer wieder dasselbe. Wir präsentieren ein Konzert, alle finden es toll, dann ist es gleich wieder ausverkauft. Wir müssen dann sagen, dass es uns leid tut und dass wir noch ein paar Restkarten haben, aber um wen geht's hier eigentlich?
Fritz präsentiert...
Diesen Sonntag.
Die letzten Karten für Dave Gaar haben bei mir im Caroma Club an.
Samstag Nachmittag.
Wo ja auch noch die Regenwahrscheinlichkeit eine Rolle spielt. Da ist es ja so. Entweder man hat sich warm angezogen, geht raus, es regnet nicht, dann hat man wieder ein Regenmännchen an, wird berühmt, ist er getroffen.
Caroma Club.
Die Sendung für Freizeitprofis.
Samstag von 14 bis 18 Uhr.
Formidable Arbeit von DJ Cole aus Wien. Chaos Computer Club bestreitet heute Abend das Chaos Radio auf Ritz im Blue Moon die letzten 20 Minuten. Der Frank, mir gegenüber sitzend, er gähnt gerade, macht sich also bereit. Voll frisch der Mann. Und mein Name, Max von Malocki. Dachchen. 80 Jahre Radio, das Thema heute Abend also. Radio an und für sich und am Telefon, wie gerade eben auch schon kurz der Christian, der sie aufgeregt hat, dass er immer die gleichen Songs hört. Hab ich doch richtig verstanden, oder?
Ja genau, das ist dann hauptsächlich das Schadbrecher Gedudel, wie das schon mal angeklungen ist, vorhin, zwischenzeitlich. Also das ist das Meiste zumindest auf dem lokalen Radio. Und deshalb ich das im Prinzip auch nur noch zu bestimmten Zeiten höre. Und mir ist auch aufgefallen, dass wenn ich dann, wenn ich den früheren Favoriten-Sender NDR 2 einmache, dass der ähnlich klingt. Und mittlerweile fange ich an, übers Internetmusik zu hören. Jetzt zum Beispiel euch das erste Mal Fritz live. Früher habe ich das nur bei ChaosCars und Audio runtergeladen.
Und jetzt hörst du uns über den mp3-Stream auch.
Genau. Und das eigene Zusammenstellen, das ist eine Möglichkeit, die ich sehe. Wobei ich schließlich, wenn ich jetzt die 80er Jahre Stream habe, wenn ich zum Beispiel Choice-Radio sehe, was ein Kollege von mir hört, das kann es ja auch nicht sein. Da hat man nur eine Musikrichtung und es werden im Prinzip immer nur dieselben Titel wiederholt. Natürlich, wenn da jetzt nicht 500 Titel sind oder 5.000 Titel, dann hört man dann dauert es länger, bis das Titel wieder kommt, aber es ist trotzdem dasselbe.
Das ist natürlich auch ziemlich schwierig, wenn man sich sein Radio selber zusammenstellen soll, hat man auch Arbeit damit. Das willst du ja nicht unbedingt haben, sich durch irgendwie eine Titel-Library zu fuschelieren ist ja auch wirklich ein Unterfangen. Cool ist natürlich, also dieses Prinzip, was wir vorhin hatten, Kunden, die das mögen, mögen auch das, dieses berühmte Prinzip. Es ist natürlich nicht schlecht, wenn du sagst, geben sie mal 100 Titel ein, die sie mögen, hier in unserer Library und dann sucht er dir danach immer auch was Neues aus, was dem entspricht.
Also diese intelligenten Datenbanken, also da habe ich im Moment noch keine Rede vorstellen, von wie das auszusehen hat, weil das ist ja auch von der Bedienung her nicht, muss das ja auch ausgefallen sein, das ist so eine Sache. Das andere ist, früher gab es auch ein häufiger Wohnsendung, mich wundert, dass das so weit zurückgegangen ist. Ich frage mich, wie das früher realisiert werden konnte, wenn das so heute kaum noch gemacht wird.
Na ja, auf Fritz gibt es ja schon zum Beispiel noch eine Stunde.
Ich meine jetzt diese Titel vom Sendung, wo man anrufen konnte und dann wurde was gespielt.
Das gibt es bei Fritz noch, nennt sich die Openbox, kommt eine Stunde am Tag von 19 bis 20 Uhr. Das wird allerdings so gemacht, dass dann über den Tag die ganzen Sachen gesammelt werden und am nächsten Tag werden sie dann in der Regel erfüllt. Weil so live erfüllen geht ja kaum.
Ja, das ist schwierig, also wenn dann müsstest du, dann brauchst du immer schon ein paar Stunden vorlaufen.
Ja, das ist auch so, wird auch so gemacht. Ja, die Abwechslung, ja, das ist alles sehr, sehr schwer zu realisieren. Christian, wir haben nicht mehr so viel Zeit, wir haben noch ein paar Leute in der Leitung. Vielen Dank für den Beitrag.
Ja, wünsche ich noch einen schönen Abend.
Dir auch. Grüß dich. Tschüss. Und die Susanne ist am Telefon. Hi Susanne.
Ja, man muss ja ganz schön Geduld haben, um euch zu euch durchzukommen. Meine Güte, das habe ich ja nicht gehört.
Ja, es tut uns auch ein bisschen leid, aber beim Chaosradio ist es Tradition, immer ein bisschen umfangreicher zu formulieren und vielleicht mal eine kleine Parenthese einzuschieben.
Ja, ich wollte mal eine Lanze brechen für Fritz und seine Gewinnspiele, weil ich bin glücklicher Gewinner geworden. Ich weiß nicht, ob euch noch dran erinnert, das war diese, der Sommer geht weiter Aktion, Mitte September oder so und da konnte man ganz am Ende eine Reise gewinnen und die habe ich gefunden.
Ich bin nach Zahiti gefahren vor zwei Wochen.
Ich bin wirklich leibhaftig dahin gefahren, es ist kein Ersatzmoderator dahin gefahren und ich war da wirklich und ich habe Fotos mitgebracht.
Wie wichtig ist dir denn sowas, dass da Radiosender auch so ehrlich sind?
Also, ich finde es einfach gut, dass ich das selbst erlebt habe, dass es funktioniert. Also, das ist nicht die erste Sache, die ich gewonnen habe. Ich habe schon so kleinen Kram, so wie CDs und so weiter und das macht das Ganze halt einfach viel persönlicher und ich habe das Gefühl, das ist irgendwie ehrlich und ich höre es einfach dann auch viel lieber.
Wenn du jetzt wüsstest, irgendwie mein wegen Fritz würde das jetzt ausgemacht, dann würden irgendwelche Leute dann diese Preise kriegen, oder auch nicht, oder wie auch immer. Und sonst wäre es aber ein total guter Sender. Wäre das denn praktisch für dich so ein K.O.-Kriterium?
Du meinst, wenn ich wüsste, dass das gefaked ist?
Ja. Also, wenn alles sonst irgendwie prima ist, nur irgendwie genau diese Gewinnspielsachen.
Aber naja, das gehört ja dazu. Also, wenn ich weiß, dass die Leute an der Stelle tricksen, dann kann ich sie auch nicht mehr sympathisch finden. Dann fehlt halt irgendwie die, dann kann ich sie nicht ehrlich finden. Und dann sag ich immer, wenn ich jetzt denke, ach, das war ja nett, dann denke ich in meinem nächsten Atemzug, aber eigentlich doch nicht. Also, das gehört schon zum Gesamtkonzept.
Naja, also ich glaub mal, wenn die Leute die Auffassungsgabe besitzen, sich darüber zu ärgern, dass sowas passiert, dass so ein Fake stattfindet, dann ist die Auffassungsgabe der Leute auch so hoch, dass sie, wenn sie den Sender hören, feststellen, dass ihnen der Sender nicht gefällt, weil der grundsätzlich scheiße ist. Dazu musst du das nicht hinterrücks erfahren. Also ich glaube, das ist sowas, das merkst du sofort, dass das dann nicht dein Ding ist. Mit diesen Gewinnspielen, 90% der Leute interessieren sich einen Dreck dafür, was da passiert und was hinter den Kulissen abgeht. Das sind nur 10% der Leute, wenn überhaupt, die da Einblicke wollen. Glaube ich.
Na dann bin ich einer von den 10 wahrscheinlich.
Sie haben beide Reisen nach Tahiti gewonnen. Sie sind einer von den 10%. Wie war es denn in Tahiti? Dann lass uns doch wenigstens ein bisschen teilhaben.
Naja, war total großartig und ich will ehrlich gesagt wieder zurück. Ich frage mich, warum ich da weggefahren bin.
Glaubst du da Palmen?
Palmen und warmes Wasser und freundliche Menschen, das gibt es gar nicht. Die sind alle total nett, das glaubst du nicht. Die sagen Bonjour die ganze Zeit und du kannst nichts anderes als auch Bonjour sagen und grinsen.
Dann kommen wir zurück nach Deutschland. Hier ist irgendwie alles grau und alle Leute sind irgendwie so... und U-Bahn und Städte.
Minus 25 Grad, ein milder Winter in Berlin Brandenburg.
Was würdest du noch besser machen am Radio? Was wäre so dein, sag ich gar, Verbesserungsvorschlag, wenn du sagst, das muss auf jeden Fall irgendwie noch anders werden?
Na ich meine, was ich jetzt so über die Jahre hinweg irgendwie gesehen habe, oder was halt ganz offensichtlich war, dass Fritz halt sich ganz offensichtlich auch so ein bisschen mehr an den Mainstream anpassen musste, was so die Tagsüber-Musik angeht. Und das finde ich halt einerseits schade, weil ich kann es mir tagsüber, ehrlich gesagt, nicht mehr so richtig oft anhören, weil ich musste heute Morgen Martin Kliritschi hören, und da habe ich gedacht, oh Gott. Aber andererseits kann ich es auch verstehen, weil es natürlich auch um Quoten und Prozent und keine Ahnung, um alles Mögliches geht. Und solange ich dann noch die Spaten-Sendung habe abends, dann kann ich das auch noch tolerieren. Und ich finde, sonst habt ihr echt ein gutes Händchen von Moderatoren. Also das sind halt alles Charaktere. Das findet man halt bei den anderen Sendern, da kannst du ja gar nicht drüber reden, das kannst du ja gleich vergessen. Und von daher, also was ich wirklich gerne hätte, das hat irgendwie ein Mädelfon auch schon gesagt, werden so richtig mehr Hörspiele. Was ihr ja schon habt, ist dieses Radio, dieses Krimiding, wo man so mitmachen kann, das finde ich auch sehr nett. Aber vielleicht noch mal so eine ruhige, einfach nur so zwei Stunden Hörspielecke finde ich super.
Ja, übrigens am Freitagabend.
Hab ich gehört, hab ich gehört, finde ich sehr spannend.
Abend der Angst, das wird sehr, sehr geil.
Aber das ist doch auch teilweise live, das habe ich nicht ganz verstanden. Also live und im Radio oder wie?
Also man kann ja wohl auch Karten gewinnen.
Ja, ich glaube ja. Das Problem ist, ist natürlich jetzt peinlich, ich arbeite hier, ich habe es auch noch nicht genau verstanden. Ich habe es mir noch nicht, ich habe es nur, ich habe es selber nur auch nur in einem Trailer gehört, also so ein Ding, was zwischendurch läuft, Abend der Angst, und ich kriege immer so viel Schiss, weil der Trailer so gut produziert ist und immer so ist, mein Gesicht, was ist mit meinem Gesicht passiert, dass ich immer denke, oh Gott, mein Gesicht, was ist mit meinem Gesicht? Deswegen, ich kann da immer nicht genau hinhören zu den Infos. Ich weiß nur, dass an dem Abend wird es geil und ich werde wahrscheinlich einschalten. Stimmt, es gibt Karten, man kann live dabei sein, richtig. Es ist halt etwas mit live zu tun.
Ich finde diesen Sonntag, Mittag, das ist der Cleo Fischer-Geschicht, hier finde ich unheimlich innovativ, aber es ist eine gute Mischung zwischen Hörspiel und Leute können aber auch mitmachen. Es muss eigentlich auch irgendwie fürchterlich kompliziert sein, sowas zu produzieren, sowas vorzubereiten, weil du auf so viele Eventualitäten gefasst sein musst. Du musst das ja auch alles in diese zwei Stunden werden. Wenn du da jetzt einen Haufen von nur Dappen hast, die einfach nicht auf diese Lösung kommen, was machst du da?
Manchmal merkt man dann auch, dass große Tipps gegeben werden und dass dann plötzlich die Lösung da ist. Aber ich finde das auch sehr spannend und würde gerne wissen, wie die das realisieren, weil das scheint echt sehr...
Das ist ganz schön kompliziert. Wenn man da am Wochenende immer da ist, wenn die das machen, die haben halt unglaublich komplexe Möglichkeiten, sich auch mit Handzeichen zu verständigen, weil die natürlich ohne was sagen zu müssen, wenn die Mikrofone offen sind, geht noch nicht. Dann machen die sich halt klar, okay, wir machen jetzt das und das und das, du machst jetzt bitte das und das auf und so weiter. Die Vorproduktion des Ganzen, so kleine Elemente werden auch vorproduziert, das einzustreuen ins Live-Ding zusammen mit dem Schauspieler, der da steht und Cleo Fischer selbst, ist schon Respekt angesagt. Okay, Susanne, dann drücke ich dir die Daumen für den Kartenzwerg-Zombie.
Okay, danke für den Anruf, tschüss.
Und wir haben noch ein paar Minuten, der Lasse aus Braunschweig, hallo Lasse.
Also ich muss sagen, ich denke mal, das Radio ist wieder ein bisschen im Kommen in der nächsten Zeit, weil ich selber höre ziemlich viel Radio, hab kein Fernsehen, aber wenn ich mal gucke, dann stelle ich fest, dass da nur Mist läuft und das ergibt mir auch ganz schnell die Lust.
Und dann will ich doch lieber wieder Radio hören.
Weil da gibt es, sag ich mal, die nervige Werbung nicht und so weiter.
Und Radio kann man einfach mal wirklich am Stück mal durchhören. Und beim Fernsehen wird das andauernd unterbrochen und so.
Es macht einfach keinen Spaß mehr.
Ich denke mal, früher war das anders. Und mittlerweile schalten noch immer mehr Leute zu Web-Radios zum Beispiel. Und ich denke, wenn im nächsten Digitalradio mehr boomt wieder, dann wird das ein richtiger Hype werden. Und dann werden mehr Leute wieder Radio hören.
Das haben wir heute schon mal gehört, dass das Radio kommen wird.
Das Radio kommt.
Das macht mir Hoffnung.
Das ist ja auch mein Arbeitsplatz irgendwie. Und glaubst du, dass sich das Radio auch verändern wird in dem Zuge? Oder glaubst du, das wird einfach nur wieder auf einer breiteren Basis stehen?
Erst mal wird sich, denke ich, nicht verändern, was ich allerdings schade finde.
Weil, wie gesagt, beim Radio ist es ja eine sparten Sache im Augenblick, dass man also auch eine Menge Mainstream hört. Und ich fände es besser, wenn einfach ein bisschen mehr gemischte Sachen spielen. Man kann ja Mainstream-Sender hören, habe ich nicht dagegen. Aber dass man ab und zu mal unregelmäßigen Abständen mal einen Song hört, den man so gar nicht kennt, weil da schaltet man nicht um. Beim Fernsehen ist es ja so, da gucke ich wirklich in die Programmzeitung, das will ich sehen, das will ich sehen, das will ich sehen. Beim Radio macht man normalerweise einen Sender an, hört den. Und da hört man auch wirklich mal Sachen, die man eigentlich gar nicht so gewollt hat. Und das finde ich eigentlich gar nicht schlecht. Da hört man auch mal Sachen, die man sich sonst nicht gekauft hätte, und kommt auf einen anderen Geschmack und bleibt einfach nicht so eingeschränkt dadurch.
Das ist dieses Zeitungsprinzip, was ich vorhin auch meinte. Also du kriegst einfach mal was vorgesetzt, wo du irgendwie nicht mitrechnest, was du dir auch sonst freiwillig nicht ausgewählt hättest.
Genau.
Eine andere Sache ist noch, dass beim Fernsehen wird man ziemlich stark durch Bilder beeinflusst auch. Beim Radio hört man sich eine Sendung an, zum Beispiel einen Bericht über den Irak-Krieg, der erstmal aktueller ist. Und zweitens überlegt man da wieder, beim Fernsehen hat man gleich Bilder dazu, assoziiert die teilweise und wird dann gleich in so eine Richtung reingedrückt irgendwie. Das hat man beim Radio nicht. Da wird man, ich denke mal, ein bisschen objektiver für sich selber auch.
Das ist ein meinungsbildendes Medium.
Ja, genau.
Ich glaube, es ist auch wirklich schwieriger im Radio, meinungsbildend zu wirken. Also im Fernsehen hast du wirklich diese ganz starken Bilder, die ganz stark sind. Und da fällt es den Sender noch einfacher zu manipulieren.
Na ja, Radio kann auch subtiler sein als Fernsehen. Also zum Beispiel kann ich ja unterschwellig sagen, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel sagen würde, wer sich bei der Telekom einen Anschluss bestellt, der muss doch gehirnamputiert sein. Das ist ein lustiger Witz. Aber irgendwie merkst du dir schon, dass es gehirnamputiert sein muss, sich bei der Telekom einen Anschluss zu bestellen.
Ich glaube, das muss man schon mit so einer, also dann immer wieder bringen, immer wieder. Das muss man den Leuten auch einprägen ins Gehirn.
Gehirnamputiert ist es, sich bei der Telekom einen Anschluss zu bestellen. Das ist jetzt nicht...
Und es muss da irgendwie mehrmals am Tag so eine Rotation bringen. Und im Fernsehen ist es einfacher. Da machst du es einmal hier, zack, hier haben wir gesehen, so blöd sind die das, das und das passiert. Und dann wird da nächsten Tag von erzählt, dass ist die Wahrheit, was da kommt. Und ich glaube, das fällt im Radio zum Glück schwerer.
Na gut, es war jetzt auch ein Scherz. Es war jetzt nur ein Beispiel. Also ich habe ja auch einen Anschluss bei der Telekom. Obwohl das Gehirnamputiert... Ja, nein, es war ein Scherz. Es war wirklich jetzt nur ein Scherz gemeint. Telekom, Daumen hoch. Äh, Lasse. Gruß nach Braunschweig. Wir haben noch Benjamin und Matthias. Wir sind kurz vorm Ende. Tut uns leid. Ja, mach's gut. So, ganz auf die Fixe. Der Benjamin aus Friedrichshain. Hallo Benjamin.
Ja, ein Wünnersch, guten Abend.
Ein kurzes Statement noch von dir.
Ja, also ich bin im Radio, wie es jetzt bei euch ist, also super zufrieden. Weil ich so ziemlich alles abdeckt, was man so hören möchte. Also von der Musikrichtung her. Und das ist eigentlich ziemlich okay, finde ich. Und was ich sehr cool finde, ist, dass ihr eure Hörer mit einbezieht. In euer Radioleben sozusagen. Also ihr lasst sie einfach mit live mitmachen. Ihr macht ja diverse Aktionen und Gut-Live-Sachen, ganz viele. Ich mache selber auch ein bisschen Radio. Und was ich mir wünschen würde, wäre, wie meine Vorrednerin schon gesagt hat, meine Vorvorrednerin Hörspiele. Das finde ich ganz spannend, wenn da mehr passieren könnte.
Mehr Hörspiele, da muss ihr ja mal einen Daumen drauf haben. Wäre ich mal den Jungs Bescheid sagen und Mädels hier.
Also ich finde das total spannend, wichtig. Ich habe Kürze Fritz, seit acht Jahren oder so etwas. Oder auf anderen Radios, also früher wurden auch mehr Hörspiele gespielt. Ich bin mir da nicht so sicher, aber ich glaube schon.
Hörspiele sind natürlich ganz, ganz, ganz kostspielig. Teures Zeug.
Willst du wirklich Hörspiele haben oder auch gerne mal Infobeiträge? Also einfach Sachen zum konzentriert zuhören. Geht es dir darum, einfach mal so konzentrierten Input zu kriegen? Oder wirklich Hörspiele im Sinne von einer Geschichte ins Hörspiel?
Also sowohl als auch, also Informationen. Deswegen höre ich auch Radio. Also ich gucke in Fern. Also aus Protests schon nicht. Ich habe zwar einen Fernseher, aber auch keinen Fernsehanschluss. Deswegen bin ich auch in Anführungsstrichen jetzt um Radio zu hören. Aber ja, Informationen bitte ich immer für zu haben. Deswegen höre ich außerdem auch Radio. Also Zeitung und Radio sind echt so die Medien, wo ich mich informieren tue. Aber ich finde Hörspiele immer entspannend. Weil es Spaß macht, da zuzuhören.
Da hört man konzentriert Radio.
Und das ist eine nette Beschäftigung.
Und Hörbücher? Also das einfach, wenn man ein Buch vorliest in Teilen oder so?
Kommt auf das Buch drauf an. Aber da kann man ja verschiedene Bücher dann lesen.
Also sagen wir es mal so als Ansatz. Wir sehen das Chaosradio immer als 3-Stunden-Feature mit höherer Beteiligung. Das ist doch etwas.
So könnte man das auch sehen. Nicht schon so, dass man Leute anrufen könnte. Kein anderer Sender, vielleicht nach Radio 1, bin ich mir nicht sicher. Sicher leistet sich sowas ohne Werbeunterbrechung, eine höhere Sendung gestalten zu lassen.
Das ist geil, wir könnten jetzt noch ewig weiter machen, aber wir haben leider nur noch 5 Minuten. Benjamin, mach's gut, wir machen Matthias jetzt schnell noch. Matthias, du bist der Letzte in der Runde.
Das Schlusswort.
Wunderbar. Mir ist mal aufgefallen über den Abend heute, dass für viele der Radio-Bereich so bei 87, 5 anfängt, bei 108 wieder aufhört. Aber nebenbei gibt es noch ein paar andere Übertragungswege. Also jetzt, über mp3-Stream, über das Netz mal abgesehen, bin ich hier schon vor Jahren mal an die Grenze vom Berliner Radiomarkt gestoßen, hab mich alles bloß noch gestört, was hier läuft, und hab mir gedacht, naja, über Satellit gibt's ja im Prinzip ein riesiges Angebot, also sowohl an Deutschsprachigen Stationen, also zum Beispiel die ganzen öffentlich-rechtlichen, alles vertreten, aber eben auch international, je nachdem, wie man die Sprache halt kann. So, und da bin ich halt, hab ich irgendwann mal angefangen, erstmal aus Großbritannien alles Mögliche mir mal anzuhören, so alle Stationen hier mal durch für ein paar Tage, bis hier irgendwas hier fällt. Und dann, gemerkt, aha, mit relativ viel Regenaufwand, also 90 Zentimeter Spiegel an der Wand, bekommst du ja noch viel mehr rein. Und jetzt bin ich, naja, im Prinzip hab ich einen halben Erdball mit meiner Schüssel drin und mir da auch schon so ein kleine privater Programmpaket zusammenschnürt, also Sonntag ist Südafrika dran, Montag die BBC und für den Rest der Woche ist das auch fertig gesorgt. Und ja, also, on demand ist ja schön und gut, aber wie auch schon einige gesagt haben, ab und zu ist man halt doch mal daran interessiert, wenn wieder mal ein Album hier und da vorgestellt wird, was auch nicht unbedingt jetzt im Deutschland einen großen Airplay bekommt, sondern eben, naja, Multikulti. Und da, finde ich, ist die Schlüssel die absolute, naja, eigentlich die Lösung schlechthin.
Das ist doch mal ein schöner Ausblick fürs Ende. So als Schlusswort ist vielleicht inspirierend für den einen oder anderen, sich eine Schüssel nicht für irgendeinen dummen Fernsehsender hinzuhängen, sondern für einen Radiosender.
Da hören uns auch ganz, ganz viele zu über Satellit.
Ja, und wenn ich mir mal die Radiosenderliste angucke, die hört zurzeit bei 855 auf.
Gruß nach Hellersdorf. Das war's mit dem Chaosradio.
Hat Spaß gemacht.
Hat super viel Spaß gemacht. Danke, dass ihr angerufen habt. Wir haben uns das nicht so locker vorgestellt. Wir haben gedacht, oh man, das könnte akademisch werden. Und wir müssen selber viel reden. Wir haben natürlich wieder selber viel geredet. Aber ihr auch. Und es hat wirklich, wirklich, wirklich Spaß gemacht. Das merkt ihr ja daran, wie wir auch da drin aufgegangen sind. Wenn ihr uns noch eine Mail schicken wollt, irgendwie...
Genau, 86 at chaosradio.ccc.de. Allgemeine Sachen an chaosradio.ccc.de. Also wenn ihr irgendwelche Nachfragen habt, Sendungswünsche, also Themenwünsche oder sowas habt. An 1986 at chaosradio.ccc.de für alles, was zu dieser Sendung gehört.
Und damit du keinen Ärger kriegst, sag ich nochmal, da ist der CCC auch dieses Jahr wieder seinen jährlichen Kongress veranstaltet, vom 27. bis zum 29. Dezember im Berliner Kongresszentrum Alex.
Genau. Und da kommt ihr bitte alle. Weil es wird wieder ganz groß und macht viel Spaß.
Wir machen jetzt gar nicht groß die Werbetrommel. Ihr kommt einfach alle. Ja, weil stell dir vor, du hättest Tim Pritt-Leo, würde dich ein Kopf kürzer gemacht.
Wir haben ja noch ein paar Tage Zeit bis dahin. Nochmal danke an Stefan aus Wien, aus dem DJ-Kohle.
DJ-Kohle ist der Künstlername, Mann.
Und für drei Stunden nette Musikuntermalung hier.
Vielen, vielen Dank. Da kommt das Nicken aus dem Hintergrund. Unsere Namen sind Max von Malodki, Frank Rosengard und steht kein Dritter mehr. Deswegen hätten wir so einen Unter zwischen setzen können. Aber Komma tut es auch. Wir sagen Tschüss und sagen viel Spaß beim Knife Flight mit Martin Petersdorf. Macht's gut!